ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
ORANGE COUNTY HOMELESSNESS AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES HEARING.
I'M ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA REPRESENTING NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY THE SIXTY FIFTH DISTRICT
BEFORE WE BEGAN THERE ARE FEW
PANDEMIC RELATED SAFETY MEASURE
MEASURES I NEED TO PROVIDE AND
WANT TO THANK YOU IN ADVANCE
FOR YOUR COOPERATION AND
UNDERSTANDING. EVEN THOUGH THIS
HEARING IS VIRTUAL ANY
INDIVIDUAL IN THE HEARING ROOM
INCLUDING STAFF AND TECHNICAL
TEAM MASKS ARE REQUIRED AT ALL
TIMES AS WELL AS THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. DUE TO THE
STRUCTURE OF THE ASSEMBLY
VIRTUAL SYSTEM WE WILL NOT HAVE
A QUESTION AND ANSWER PERIOD
AFTER EACH PANEL. HOWEVER THE
GENDER INCLUDES TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER THE THIRD AND
FINAL PANEL. IN ORDER FOR YOU
TO ASK A QUESTION OR MAKE A
COMMENT YOU WILL NEED TO CALL.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AGAIN.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND USE
THE PIN CODE POUND ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN.
POUND. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. THIS NUMBER WILL
ALSO BE PROVIDED ON THE SCREEN
DURING THE HEARING. THE HEARING
WILL END AT ONE PM AND I WILL
TRY TO TAKE AS MANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AS POSSIBLE AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COOPERATION.
AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON ORANGE COUNTY
HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WELCOME TO OUR FIRST
HEARING OF THIS SESSION HOWEVER
WE HELD IT IN DISTRICT HEARING
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS AND BOY
IN A PARK. TWO YEARS AGO. THIS
TOPIC IS SOMETHING THAT I AM
QUITE PASSIONATE ABOUT WORK
TIRELESSLY ON AND BELIEVE THAT
WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE AS A
COMMUNITY AS A COUNTY AS
NEIGHBORS AS LOCAL ELECTED. AS
LONG AS WE HAVE THE SAME GOAL
IN MIND WHICH IS TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS AND TO DO WHAT WE
CAN TOGETHER TO SOLVE THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. THE GOAL FOR
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO FOCUS ON
THE PROGRESS THAT THE REGION
HAS MADE WHAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND THE
ROLE EACH ONE OF US CAN PLAY. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE MANY
ROAD BALOCHS TO PROVIDING
HOUSING FOR THE COUNTY'S
GROWING POPULATION OF
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS. PEOPLE AS
WELL AS SERVICES FOR THOSE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. WE ALSO
KNOW THERE ARE NO SIMPLE
ANSWERS TO ADDRESS SUCH COMPLEX
PROBLEMS HOWEVER IT DOES TAKE
DEDICATION AND COLLABORATION TO
SUPPORT THOSE WHO LACK SAFE
STABLE AND APPROPRIATE PLACES
TO LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY. AS
WELL AS TO ACCESS VARIOUS
LEVELS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
DID YOU KNOW THAT IN EVERY
MONTH AND THE LAST CALENDAR
YEAR IN ORANGE COUNTY ALMOST OR
CLOSE TO THIRTY PEOPLE HAVE
DIED ON ORANGE COUNTY STREETS.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE BETTER WE
NEED TO BETTER UNDERSTAND AND
ADDRESS CONTRIBUTING FACTORS OF
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS SUCH AS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ABUSE. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND
DEDICATION TO IF YOU ARE A
SERVICE PROVIDER A NONPROFIT A
HOUSING AND GIVE ADVOCATE A
NEIGHBOR A LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIAL COUNTY OFFICIAL WE
KNOW THAT WHAT YOU DO MAKES A
DIFFERENCE. AGAIN I BELIEVE IT
TAKES ALL OF US TO SUPPORT AND
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. CITIZENS AND
RESIDENTS IN ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE PANELISTS AHEAD OF TIME
AND ORGANIZATIONS AND ADVOCATES
WELL WE WOULD NOT BE MAKING THE
PROGRESS THAT WE ARE SEEN IN
ORANGE COUNTY WITHOUT YOUR
SUPPORT. LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
PANELONE ON THIS PANEL IS
FOCUSED ON MENTAL HEALTH
COMMUNITY NEEDS IN SERVICES. I
WILL JUST PUT A LITTLE HYPHEN
HERE THAT IT'S NOT JUST
HOMELESSNESS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THAT HAVE BEEN CRITICALLY
AFFECTED WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AS WE KNOW WITH THE
PANDEMIC. OUR STUDENTS PARENTS
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING NOT
ONLY WITH THE FEAR OF THE
VIBRANT VIRUS BUT ALSO LOSING
ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF OF
SCHOOLING. OUR FIRST PANELISTS
ARE MISTER CLINTON CHILD WHO IS
THE DIRECTOR AND COUNTY OFFICE
OFFICER FOR THAT COUNTY HEALTH.
HEALTH CARE AGENCY. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH MR
CLAIMED SHALL ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS AND I'M DELIGHTED
THAT HE IS HERE WITH US IN
ADDITION WE HAVE MR MATH HOPE
MATTHEW HOLES MAN WHO IS THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS LIAISON
FOR NAOMI ORANGE COUNTY. AND DR
HEATHER. HOOT SEE SORRY IS THE
CHAIR OF THE DIVISION OF THE
PEDIATRIC PSYCHIATRY FOR THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL OF ORANGE
COUNTY OR BETTER KNOWN AS CHALK
HOSPITAL. WITH THAT WE WELCOME
YOU AND WE ARE GOING TO BEGAN
WITH OUR FIRST PANELIST WITH
WHO IS. MR CLAYTON SHALL.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY WOMAN QUIT
SILVA AND DHEA HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO-
ATTEMPTS TO YOU THIS MORNING-
I'M DELIGHTED THAT I'M JOINED
BY MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES HERE.
I CAN KNOW EVERYBODY AND ALL
THE PANELS THAT YOU PUT
TOGETHER SO YOU GET THE RIGHT
FOLKS TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
AND I'M A WOULD PLAZA I WOULD I
WOULD START THE CONVERSATION.
FROM A- COUNTY HEALTH OFFICERS
PERSPECTIVE VIEW OF BRIGHT-
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A MINUTE A
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY- ADDICTIONS AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
CRUCIAL AT THIS POINT IN A
PANDEMIC. A PAST WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A THIRDS THIRDS
FOURTH FOR SOME OF US ARE AS A
NATION- I THINK THAT WOULD BE-
CHILDREN COMING BACK TO SCHOOL
AFTER BEING MOST OF THEM BEING
OUT AT HOME IN THE LOCKDOWN FOR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS NOW. IT IS
GONNA. TAKE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF. YEAH FOR THE TO THE- NO- AT
THE END THAT WOULD INCLUDE A
HOW TO KEEP HOW DO THEY KEEP
THEMSELVES SAFE. AND NOT GET
INFECTED. AND BRING BACK HOME
ARE HOW DO THEY KEEP THEIR A
CLASSMATE SAVE BY NOT BRINGING
THE VIRUS. INTO THE SCHOOL AND
SPREAD IT TO THEIR CLASSMATES
BECAUSE THAT'S YOU KNOW AT THE
NATIONAL EFFORT S. WALLS
CALIFORNIA EFFORT WE ARE MOVING
TOWARDS. AN EFFORT TO BRING ALL
CHILDREN BACKED INTO IN PERSON
EDUCATION BECAUSE WE KNOW.
ONLINE EDUCATION. HAVE NOT
WORKED OUT FOR THE YOUNGSTER
AND WE HAVE SEEN ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE DROPPED IN A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THOSE
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE FROM
BONOBO COMMUNITIES- AND THEN
WE'VE ALSO SEEN ANXIETY. AND
QUESTIONS AND THOSE WHO'VE BEEN
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CLASSMATES
BECAUSE THAT'S THE NATURE OF
CHILDREN THEY NEED TO BE AMONG
THEMSELVES. THEY NEED TO BE IN
SCHOOL TO LEARN HOW TO
SOCIALIZE WITH THEIR CLASSMATES
AND HOW TO SOCIALIZE WITH THE
ADULTS IN THEIR LIFE. AT THE
TEACHER IN THE SCHOOL STAFF AND
WHAT HAPPENED YOU SO WE ARE
FACING- AT A CRITICAL TIME AND
HOW DO WE PROVIDE A SUPPORT FOR
THE STUDENTS. AND THEN FOR THE
FAMILY THE PARENTS AT HOME WHO
NERVOUS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH MY KIDS WHAT
THEY BRING THE VIRUS HOME
ETCETERA AND THEN FALL TEACHER
ESPECIALLY TEACHER WHO HAVE
HOPE- WHAT IN HIGH RISK
CATEGORY. I'LL TELL YOU THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE TEACHERS OR
TEACHER THAT I HEARD FROM IS
JUST AMAZING MANY OF THEM ARE
WILLING. TO BRING THE CHILDREN
BACK TO WORK WITH THE CHILDREN
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IN IT EVEN
THOUGH THEY THEMSELVES ARE
PEOPLE AT THE HIGH RISK
CATEGORY SO YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT MA'AM. WE REALLY NEED
TO HAVE A ROBUST SYSTEM MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. THAT WOULD
SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY. IN THIS
TIME AND TIME I DON'T- GIVEN
WHAT OF MENTIONS AS A RELATED
HOMELESS AND I MIGHT SOME THAT
PEOPLE WILL THIS IS A WITH BUT
THAT WHAT WHO ARE HOMELESS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND ADDICTIONS
AND ACCESS TO TREATMENT IS VERY
COMPLEX AS YOU POINTED OUT IT'S
NOT EASY I CAN TELL YOU IN
ORANGE COUNTY JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAVE SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS ON THE STREET
I'M NOT STRANGER TO US. HEALTH
SYSTEM WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE WE
HAVE TRIED YEARS FOR YEARS TO
ENGAGE THEM INTO TREATMENT BUT-
IN OUR COUNTRY THE RIGHT TO
REFUSE TREATMENT. IT IS THE
FUNDAMENTAL. AND I'M IN MY
OPINION THAT IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY
IT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE FOR US TO ENGAGE
PEOPLE IN TREATMENT- ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY ARE IN THE MIDST OF
THEIR- EPISODE WHETHER IT BE
SEVERE MANIA ARE SEVERE
PSYCHOSIS- IS THAT THERE'S NOT
THAT RECOGNITION THAT TREATMENT
IS IMPORTANT FOR THAT BRACKET.
AND SO YES WE HAVE HAD SUCCESS
IN ORANGE COUNTY I'M SO PROUD
OF THE PARTNERS IN THE PANEL
WILL BE WORKING SO HARD FOR
DECADES. TO TRY TO GET HOUSING
ARE BOTH A RESIDENTS HERE IN IN
IN ORANGE COUNTY BUT YOU KNOW
THE HOUSING MARKET IN ORANGE
COUNTY IT'S NOT A PERFECT PLACE
FOR US TO DO THAT. IT IS VERY
EXPENSIVE AND YOU CAN'T DO IT
RIGHT AND I KNOW WE HAVE GOTTEN
COOPERATION AND PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN PRIVATE AND PUBLIC AND
PHILANTHROPIST AND WE MADE SOME
HEADWAY. TO OF GARNER'S WE
SOURCES TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING A FILE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS INCLUDING
INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE HOMELESS BUT
THAT IS NOT ENOUGH. PLEASE TELL
PAPRIKA AND I'M AFRAID THAT
THIS PANDEMIC HAS EVEN COST
MORE PEOPLE AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS SO COMPOUNDED BY
ANXIETY DEPRESSION AND
ADDICTION RIGHT- ABOUT PAIN USE
OF PICK UP A PRESCRIPTION
PAINKILLERS. USE UP ILLICIT
DRUGS ON TOP OF A PRISONER
BEING HOMELESS. WHAT WE ARE
ABOUT TO ENTER INTO A PHASE
MORE FACT FROM TO PREDICT TWO
HOW TO DO THIS AND SO I KNOW I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE MUCH TIME
BECAUSE I WANT TO HEAR MY OTHER
PARTNER. BUT BUT BUT STILL SOME
ONE THING. WE HAVE GOT TO SUIT.
ST MATTER. AND THAT MEANS WHAT
HAVE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAPPY. OF FOR. IS THE NURSES
SOCIAL. COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER. UP OUT THERE ON THE
STREETS SUPPORTING INDIVIDUAL
ON THOSE TO GET FROM THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED- BUT
MOST AT RISK BUT THE PLAN
FORTUNATE PIECES IT IS NOT EASY
FOR THEM TO GO INTO AN INDOOR
PLACE TO ACCESS SERVICES. WE
KNOW THAT IF I PUSH MY CARD
WITH MY BELONGINGS AND YOU TELL
ME TO GO TO A DOCTOR'S OFFICE
ALSO SUPPORTS WORKERS OFFICE.
WHO'S GOING TO WATCH OVER MY
CARD UP ALL MY BELONGINGS RIGHT
IT'S A WE HAVE. REALLY WE MUST
AND UPON THAT HAVE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION WITH THE WAY ON
IT'S HOW DO WE BRING ST MADISON
ONTO THE STREET. AND REALLY
TAKE CARE OF FOLKS WHO NEEDED
IT AND THEN THE SECOND PIECE
IS. HOUSING VOUCHERS OR A MOTEL
VOUCHER HAVE TO BE EASILY
pCOMMUNITY CLINIC FOR SERVICES.
AND AT THAT POINT WHEN THE
COMMUNITY CLINIC WORKER
ASSESSMENT ONE OF THEM THE
VOUCHER AVAILABLE FOR ME IF I
NEED HELP TO GET INTO A TO GET
INTO A SHELTER WHILE I'M-
TRYING TO GET MY CONDITION
STABILIZED BY. GOOD THERE WILL
BE PEOPLE WHO WON'T QUALIFY FOR
LUCRATIVE CARE BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA HAVE
CERTAIN CONDITIONS IN ORDER FOR
YOU TO MEET THE CRITERIA. CARE
WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE WHO NOT THAT
BAD THEY DON'T MEET THAT KIND
OF HELP BUT THEY JUST NEED TO
GET STABILIZED DO WE HAVE A
HOTEL VOUCHER. READILY
AVAILABLE FOR THEM TO ACCESS
RIGHT AND THEN LASTLY I WANT TO
HOP ON TO THIS ISSUE- OF THAT
THAT THE RIGHT TO REFUSE
TREATMENT WE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT. BECAUSE
WE DO KNOW THAT WE HAVE
INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE OF THE
MENTAL ILLNESS BECAUSE THIS IS
A COMMUNITY OF ADDICTION IT IS
NOT EASY FOR THEM TO STAY AT
HOME. EVEN IF WE GO WITH THE
HOUSING FOR AND GAVE THEM. A AN
APARTMENT TO STATE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T. WHAT EVENTUALLY. COST
THEM BELIEVE THAT OF SHELTER WE
KNOW THAT I SEE AS A COUPLE
MAKE NOT THAT. WE KNOW THIS FOR
A LONG TIME NOW BUT BECAUSE OF
REGULATION- WE NOT ABLE TO DO
MORE I WOULDN'T SAY MORE BUT WE
NOT ABLE TO DO WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE. TO TAKE CARE OF
THESE FOLKS SO WITH THAT I WILL
AND EAGERLY AWAITING TO HEAR
FROM MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER THANK YOU FOR GIVING
US A PLATFORM TO SHARE WITH YOU
WHAT WE KNOW AND HOPING THAT
YOU IN THAT HONORABLE COMMITTEE
WOULD HELP US. PROVIDE POLICY
BRINGING RESOURCE TO ORANGE
COUNTY FOR US TO CREATE A
REALLY SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
EVERYBODY. TO ATTRACT SEPTIC
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM
MISTER CHAU READ. YOUR
SENSITIVE COMMENTS YOU MADE A
FEW. NOTES THAT TO I HAVE TAKE
IN WHICH IS- YOU KNOW I OFTEN
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL NORMALLY
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT CITY IN
AS A FULLERTON CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR EIGHT YEARS. TWO
YEARS AS MAYOR BUT ALSO. ON
COUNCIL WHICH WAS ALMOST ELEVEN
YEARS WITH THE- KELLY THOMAS
CASE WHERE WE HAD- ARE HORRIFIC
ENCOUNTER WITH THE
SCHIZOPHRENIC YOUNG MAN IN
FULLER TEN. WE TRAIN OUR POLICE
A SOME OF OUR POLICE OFFICERS
THIS WAS ELEVEN YEARS AGO AND
IN IN MANY WAYS THAT THAT CASE
MADE NATIONAL NEWS
INTERNATIONAL NEWS BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT CONTINUES TO
DRIVE MY FOCUS. IS WHAT CAN THE
PUBLIC DO BECAUSE I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT AND WITH THAT
TWENTY PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES-
WHETHER YOU'RE DRIVING BY YOU
SEE SOMEBODY LAYING OUT OF PARK
WHETHER YOU SEE SOMEBODY LIKE
YOU SAY DRAGGING THREE AND FOUR
CARDS WHETHER YOU SEE SOMEONE
THAT. DEFINITELY LOOKS LIKE
THEY'VE NOT HAD ANY TYPE OF A
SUPPORT WHETHER IT BE FOOD OR-
WHEN THEY NEED HELP. I KNOW WE
DO HAVE SOME COMMUNITY GROUPS
OUT THERE LIKE WOUND WALK WHO
ARE OUT THERE AND AS YOU SAID
GETTING PEOPLE OUT INTO THE
FIELD TO HELP. ADDRESS MEDICAL
CONDITIONS BUT IS THERE A
CONTACT IS THERE A WAY THAT
JUST OF INDIVIDUAL. COULD DO%
SOMETHING IF THEY SEE SOMEBODY
IN CRISIS. YES YES MA'AM AND IN
ORANGE COUNTY- WE ARE TRYING TO
A STANDARDIZED AND- MOVE
TOWARDS A SINGLE NUMBER FOR
PEOPLE TO CONTACT BECAUSE AS
YOU PROBABLY ARE WELL AWARE IF
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CRISIS BUT I ACTUALLY
VIGOROUSLY OVER A DOZEN THE
PHONE NUMBER THAT YOU COULD
CALL AND IT'S CREATES SO MUCH
CONFUSION AND THEN SOME PEOPLE
ENDED UP CALLING NINE ONE ONE
RIGHT AND THEN WE'LL BALK
AUTOMOTIVES THE ROOM IT
UNNECESSARILY BOMBARDED WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT THERE
APPROPRIATELY RIGHT BECAUSE WE
HAVE OTHERS OTHER PLACES THAT.
TO DIRECTLY TO UP A PUBLICLY
AND SO I WOULD SAY THAT IN
ORANGE COUNTY IF YOU ENCOUNTER
A SITUATION LIKE THIS YEAR
PRICES YOU NEED CARE. DOESN'T
MATTER WHICH PHONE YOU HAVE
CALL- SEEDLINGS ARE O. . L. I.
N. K. S. AND IF YOU ASK ME WHAT
IS THE NUMBER I'M CONSIDERED
GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK IT UP BUT
IT'S VRY EASY. IT'S ALMOST THE
LENGTH. THAT IS ALL MA'AM SO
THAT IS THE SAME CENTRAL NUMBER
SEVEN ONE FOUR- CEILINGS THAT
PEOPLE COULD CALL. TO ACCESS TO
EITHER IS IT SOMEBODY WHO NEED
TO GO OUT IN THE VALLEY THE
PERSON FOR FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLE
OR IS IT SOMEBODY WHO CAN OUR
REACH- FOR. THE WE HAVE THE- I
WHICH AN ENGAGEMENT TEAM I CAN
GIVE YOU THE DULT OUT WHICH
ENGAGEMENTS IN NUMBER BUT WE
ENCOURAGE. THE COMMUNITY TO
ACCESS- SEA LEGS OKAY THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU SO IF
YOU ARE AN INDIVIDUAL- YOU WANT
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE YOU SEE
SOMEBODY THAT IS IN CRISIS. AND
THIS ISN'T. IN LIEU OF
REPORTING SOMEBODY BECAUSE
THEY'RE HOMELESS THIS IS
SOMEBODY WHO'S- IN CRISIS THAT
YOU REALLY BELIEVE NEEDS HELP.
YOU ARE CALLING- SEE LINKS
SEVEN ONE FOUR- SEE LINK THANK
YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY. MEMBER
NOW MA'AM. IF YOU DON'T MIND
REALLY REASONABLE NUMBER. EIGHT
FIVE FIVE. SIX TWO FIVE. FOUR
SIX FIVE SEVEN. SIX AGAIN I
MEAN WE BEAT IT. 855-625-4657
ALL RIGHT SO. EIGHT FIVE FIVE
SAY IT AGAIN. SIX TWO FIVE FOUR
SIX FIVE SEVEN. OKAY SO WE'RE
NOT USING SEVEN ONE FOUR WE'RE
USING THE LINK. 485-562-5465
SEVEN I THANK YOU THAT REALLY I
THINK AGAIN THIS IS NOT TO BE
USED BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE
SOMEBODY THAT IS HOMELESS IN A
PARK THIS IS TO BE USED BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
TO HELP SOMEBODY IN CRISIS
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MISTER
CLINTON CHAU THE DIRECTOR OF
THE COUNTY OFFICE FOR THE
ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH CARE
AGENCY. NEXT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO MR MATTHEW HOLES MAN WHO IS
THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
LIAISON FOR NOW ME AND AGAIN
SOMETIMES WHEN WE'RE IN-
OFFICES WE LEARN ACRONYMS. AND
NOT EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT NOW ME
MEANS NOW ME IS THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS AND
MANY COUNTIES AND CITIES HAVE
CHAPTERS SO THIS IS OUR ORANGE
COUNTY LIAISON MR MATTHEW
WHOLESOME WELCOME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE PANELISTS AND
GUESTS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY. MY NAME IS
MATT HOLZMAN AND I'M CHAIR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
DISORDERS COUNTY AFFILIATE. AMY
ORANGE COUNTY REPRESENTS
INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE ARE A NATIONAL VOICE FOR THE
VOICELESS. OUR MISSION IS TO
EDUCATE THE DE STIGMATIZE
MENTAL ILLNESSES AND TO EMPOWER
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR FAMILIES
TO BECOME THE BEST POSSIBLE
VERSIONS OF OURSELVES. IN ORDER
TO DO THIS NAME YOU WANT TO
COUNTY HAS A WIDE RANGE OF
EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOR FAMILIES
AND CAREGIVERS. INDIVIDUALS
WILL PUT EXPERIENCE. HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS. ALL THAT AT NO COST.
EDUCATION HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOL IN
REDUCING HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
IMPROVING OUTCOMES AND THERE
ARE MANY STUDIES THAT HAVE
SHOWN THIS. WHEN THE FAMILY AN
INDIVIDUAL OR EDUCATED INVOLVED
BETTER DECISIONS CAN BE MADE
AND FRICTION IS REDUCED. THIS
CORRECTION IS AT THE HEART OF
OUR EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO
MENTAL ILLNESS. I'M HERE AS
WELL AS A PARENT OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
TWO OF OUR CHILDREN WERE ON THE
STREETS AND SUFFERED FROM
ADDICTION. AND SMR. ONE DIED BY
SUICIDE THE OTHERS IN RECOVERY.
I'VE SPENT TIME COMBAT COMBING
THE STREETS FOR CHILDREN
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE JAILS BETTER TREATMENT
FACILITIES. THE TRUMP EARNED.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO IMPROVE THE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY MENTAL HEALTH
OUTCOMES FOR THE HOMELESS IN
ORANGE COUNTY. MUCH HAS BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED. BUT THERE'S MUCH
MORE TO DO. IN ORANGE COUNTY WE
DON'T HAVE OUTREACH WORKERS
CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS TO
SERVICES. WE'RE ALSO PILOTING
PROGRAMS APPEAR A CLINICIAN AND
APPEAR TO RESPOND TO MENTAL
HEALTH GOALS RATHER THAN ONE
FORSMAN. HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT ON
HOUSING FIRST INITIATIVES. AND
THE BE WELL SITE IN ORANGE IS
IN FULL OPERATION. BUT THE
ESSENCE OF PREVENTION IS
EDUCATION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. WE'RE THE SYSTEM
FALLS DOWN IS AFTER THE CRISIS.
INDIVIDUALS STABILIZE BUT WHAT
THEN. WE DO NOT HAVE WARM HAND
OFFS OFTEN NOT HOMELESS
INDIVIDUAL HAS NO ALTERNATIVE
BUT THE STREETS. THERE IS NO
OFTEN NO ROOM AT THE END. WHEN
OUR SON DIED HE WAS DISCHARGED
FROM A PSYCHIATRIC UNIT DOSED
WITH THE COCKTAIL OF
MEDICATIONS. THE CLOTHES ON HIS
BACK. SOME PRESCRIPTIONS AND IT
WAS PASSED WITH THE INSTRUCTION
TO GO TO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT IF YOU FELT SUICIDAL
OR HOMICIDAL. THREE HOURS LATER
HE WAS DEAD. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE. IN WORKING WITH
COLLEAGUES IN EUROPE I'VE
LEARNED THE TRUE NATURE OF
WRAPAROUND CARE. BRICKS AND
MORTAR OR A PART OF THE ANSWER.
BUT CONDITIONS HAVE TO GO WHERE
THE PROBLEM LIES NOT WAIT FOR
DISASTER TO WIN ON THEIR
DOORSTEP. HOUSING AND THE RIGHT
KIND OF HOUSING IS CRITICAL.
INDIVIDUALS IN CRISIS HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS AT DIFFERENT
STAGES. SOMETIMES IT IS BEHIND
A LOCKED DOOR FOR THEIR OWN
SAFETY. THEN MAYBE IN A NON
WALKED ENVIRONMENT. BETTER TO
STEP DOWN HOUSING. THEN IT MAY
BE A GROUP HOME OR WITH FAMILY
AND ISN'T THAT REALLY THE
ULTIMATE GOAL. WE NEED SERVICES
AND HOUSING AT ALL THE STAGES.
WE DON'T HAVE NEARLY ENOUGH.
THE ECONOMICS OF GROUP HOUSING
SIMPLY DON'T WORK AND YET THERE
ARE FEWER AND FEWER MENTAL
HOSPITALS IN EUROPE EXACTLY
BECAUSE THEY FOUND THAT THESE
OPTIONS WORK. HAVING THE
CONDITIONS GO TO THE INDIVIDUAL
AND PATIENT CENTERED CARE WORKS.
M. INVOLVEMENT WORKS. THE COST
OF HOMELESSNESS IN WASTED WIVES
AS A NATIONAL STATE. ACOSTA
DOLLARS IS TREMENDOUS WE NEED
TO DO BETTER. HOUSING AT EACH
LEVEL OF CARE CASE MANAGEMENT
CLINICAL SERVICES. CRISIS
INTERVENTION IN SUPPORT OF
PROGRAMS CAN HELP US TO OFFER A
WAY UP AND OUT OF HOMELESSNESS.
WE MUST WORK HOLISTICALLY AND
BREAK DOWN THE BARRIERS BETWEEN
SILOS OF EXPERTISE. WHEN YOU
COOPERATION AND COOPERATION AND
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
ON BEHALF OF ANY ORANGE COUNTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
HOLTZMAN AND THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR PERSONAL STORY AND
I AM SO SORRY FOR THE LOSS OF
YOUR SON- I TO HAVE LOST A
BROTHER- TWO AND NOT ONLY
ADDICTION BUT- WHO DEALT WITH
HOMELESSNESS AND THOSE OF US
WHO ARE IN THAT TO. IF YOU WANT
TO SAY GROUP WHO HAVE ENDURED
THIS WE KNOW THAT MANY TIMES.
THERE IS THE STIGMA WE KNOW
THERE'S THAT BLAME. I'VE HEARD
PEOPLE SAY WHY DON'T YOU JUST
TAKE CARE OF YOUR FAMILY
INSINUATING THAT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOST FAMILY MEMBERS TO THE
STREETS ARE ADDICTIONS HAVE
NEVER TRIED TO DO THAT HAVE
NEVER TRIED TO MAKE
INTERVENTIONS- MISTER HUSBAND
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO. THOSE
THAT SAY THINGS LIKE WELL
THAT'S GREAT ALL THESE
INTERVENTIONS YOU WANT BUT WE
DON'T WANT HIM IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD WE DON'T WANT HIM
IN OUR CITY AND WE DON'T WANT
TO MEN ARE COUNTY BECAUSE- THEY
BRING CRIME AND DRUGS AND- AND-
WE JUST DON'T WANT TO HEAR.
WELL THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
MOST OF THESE PEOPLE ARE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY ORIGINALLY ANYWAY.
SO MOST OF THEM HAVE FAMILY
HERE. THEY HAVE FRIENDS HERE.
BOB THEY HAVE SERIOUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME THERE ARE- AND
SO WE HAVE TO TREAT THEM AS OUR
OWN. AND THIS IS THIS IS ALL
PART OF A CONTINUUM OF CARE. SO
WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT IT AS-
WHERE DO WE WORK WE- ENGAGE
PEOPLE WHERE WE HAVE THEM. BOB
GETTING SERVICES AND AS I AM AS
I MENTIONED IN EUROPE B.
CLINICIANS OFTEN GO TO THE
INDIVIDUAL. AND THAT'S NOT
CHEAP BUT WE HAVE TO BALANCE
THE COST OF DOING THAT VERSUS
THE COSTS OF INCARCERATION AND
BOB. HOSPITALIZATION AND THE
COST IN THE EMERGENCY ROOMS SO
WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT IT AS
A HOLISTIC OUR SYSTEM. AND I
DON'T THINK WE DO GET. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS AS I
DO THINK ORANGE COUNTY DOES
HAVE MANY MODELS THAT ARE BEST
PRACTICE MODELS AND WHERE WE
HAVE I THINK HAVE SOME. VERY
BRIGHT STARS I KNOW THAT MANY
MANY IF NOT ALL CITIES WHOSE
SOME INDIVIDUAL HOMES THAT WE
REALLY DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT
BECAUSE OF COURSE WE WANT TO
KEEP. THOSE HOMES PRIVATE
WHETHER IT'S FOR ABUSED WOMEN
WHETHER THEY'RE SHELTERS FOR
FAMILY AND WHETHER THEIR GROUP
HOMES BECAUSE WE KNOW. IT TOO
OFTEN IF THESE HOMES ARE PUT ON
A LIST- SOMETIMES FOR NO
APPARENT REASON OTHER THAN
PEOPLE DON'T WANT THAT TYPE OF
HOMES. IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
THEY COULD BE AT RISK OF BEING
SHUT DOWN. ON THE OTHER HAND WE
CERTAINLY KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN
ISSUES WITH SOME GROUP HOMES
NOT BEING REGULATED- AND THIS
IS ALSO CAUSED- THE TIDE TO
TURN AGAINST SOME OF THE
SUPPORTIVE. SERVICES WHEN WE
HAVE BAD ACTORS SO THERE HAS TO
BE A BALANCE BUT I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. I IF
YOU COULD PUT A PHONE NUMBER IN
THERE FOR AGAIN I'M LOOKING AT
BEING ABLE TO GET FAMILIES
CONNECTED TO TAP NOW ME BECAUSE
I DO KNOW. MANY FAMILIES
STRUGGLE SILENTLY THEY HAVE NO
WEAR OR IDEA I SHOULD SAY WHO
TO TURN TO SO WHAT WOULD BE
THEIR FIRST STOP IN TRYING TO
ACCESS ONLY SERVICES BUT HELP
FOR THEM NOT ONLY THEMSELVES AS
THE FAMILY. BUT FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT STRUGGLING.
WELL THE FIRST STOP WOULD BE
THE WARM WATER. AND SALT PUT
THAT IN THE TRAP. I DON'T HAVE
IT HANDY AT THE MOMENT BUT I'LL
I'LL CALL IT UP AND I WILL-
WHAT IT- OUT THERE SO THAT. WE
CAN CALL AND THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO CAN PROVIDE. A CONNECTION
TO SERVICES THERE TO LISTEN-
MOST THE MORE INDIVIDUALS WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE SO THEY WALKED
IN THE SAINT JUDE'S IS PEOPLE
CALLING. SO IT'S A VERY IT'S A
VERY EMPATHETIC AND A VERY-
USEFUL- RUBBER TO THE ROAD GOT
A SERVICE THAT WE OFFER. AND
DESPITE. WANTED MUCH BY THE
COUNTY. THAT MATTER I DO HAVE
THE NUMBER TO THE WARM LINE
OKAY. ASSEMBLY WOMAN THE NUMBER
TO THE ONE LINE IT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. NINE ONE ZERO NINE
TWO SEVEN SIX- SO IF YOU ARE
LISTENING A SECOND. SUPPORT IS
THE WARM LINE AGAIN RUN BY THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE EMPATHETIC
LISTENERS A FIRST PLACE TO
START. IF YOU OR IN AN
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY MEMBER YOU
KNOW IS STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN NINE ONE
ZERO. NINE TWO SEVEN SIX MY
TEAM WILL BE TAKING EXPLICIT
NOTES AND MAKING SURE WE GET
THIS OUT AS WELL BUT TWO
NUMBERS- SEE LINK. THIS IS IF
YOU SEE SOMEBODY MAYBE NOT A
FAMILY MEMBER OR SOMEBODY THAT
YOU SEE ON CRISIS- YOU CAN CALL
THIS NUMBER- SEE LINK. EIGHT
FIVE FIVE SIX TWO FIVE FOUR SIX
FIVE SEVEN. WARM LINE WOULD BE
IF YOU OR A FAMILY FAMILY
MEMBER IS STRUGGLING AND YOU
NEED A FIRST STOP HELP- TO
START TO NAVIGATE THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. NINE ONE ZERO NINE TWO
SEVEN SIX. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
MISTER A HOLES MEN FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND- WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING DELAYED
ORANGE COUNTY'S NAOMI. BRANCH
OUR LAST SPEAKER ON OUR FIRST
PANEL OR IS NOW DR HEATHER HOOT
SEE WHO IS THE CHAIR OF THE
DIVISION OF PEDIATRIC
PSYCHIATRY FOR THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OF ORANGE COUNTY
BETTER KNOWN AS CHOP. WELCOME
THANK YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLY
WOMEN WORK STILL BUT STILL
APPRECIATE YOUR- COMMITMENTS-
Q. FIVE MENTAL HEALTH AND- DO
YOU HAVE CHILDREN- I- THE NEW
YEAR AND I BELIEVE THE SHEDDING
LIGHT ON THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS AND THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES- AS
DOCTOR CHAO TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT I'M GONNA START UPSTREAM
A LITTLE BIT WITH ARE YOU. OP
BECAUSE REALLY THE BEST WAY TO
START TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
IS REALLY TO PROVIDE SERVICES
FOR OUR YOUTH AND- WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT UNTREATED MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ARE PARTICULARLY
STARTING IN YOU. WE NEED TO OUT
SO MANY OF THE THINGS WE WANT
TO PREVENT IN SOCIETY INCLUDING
HOMELESSNESS BUT ALSO ADDICTION
EARLY INCARCERATION DROPPING
OUT OF SCHOOLS- WE NEED TO PUT
THAT THAT EMPHASIS ON ARE YOU.
I WANTED TO JUST CENTER US FOR
A MINUTE IN THE IN A COUPLE OF
STATISTICS- AND DATA UP PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC- ONE IN FIVE
CHILDREN HAD A DIAGNOSABLE
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER DURING
THEIR CHILDHOOD. THAT IT'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND YOUTH IN ORANGE COUNTY
OP BUT ONLY ABOUT A THIRD
ACTUALLY RECEIVE SERVICES I'M
AS DOCTOR CHAO TALKED ABOUT
WITH THE PANDEMIC- BECAUSE OF
ISOLATION- THE STRESSORS I.
FAMILY STRUGGLE WITH INCOME
WE'VE SEEN A TREMENDOUS
INCREASE THE NEEDS ARE JUST
FIGURES FROM CHOC CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OF ORANGE COUNTY- THAT
OUTSIDE OF WHAT'S HAPPENED
DURING THE PANDEMIC SO WE
STARTED WITH ONE IN FIVE
CHILDREN- HERE'S WHAT WE'VE
SEEN DURING THE PANDEMIC WE'VE
HAD AN INCREASE IN CALLS OUT
LOOKING FOR OUTPATIENT
SERVICES. UP BY TWENTY EIGHT
PERCENT- WE'VE HAD A 27%
INCREASE IN OUR EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT WITH OUR KIDS COMING
IN WITH PSYCHIATRIC DIAGNOSIS
HE'S MOSTLY SUICIDAL IDEATION-
I WILL SAY TWO NIGHTS AGO WE
HAD SEVEN CHILDREN- IN R. E. D.
AWAITING PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT
BEDS- WE'VE SEEN WITH SCHOOL RE
OPENING AS DOCTORS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT WE'VE SEEN. A BIG
INCREASE AGAIN I'M IN THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN COMING IN
OUR MENTAL HEALTH INPATIENT
CENTER- SHOWED THROUGHOUT. THE
PANDEMIC AND INCREASED CENSUS
AND HI A Q. SO CHILLED WHO ARE
CO IN SEEING MORE. COME IN AND-
THEY'RE TAKE ILLNESSES ARE
WORSE SO THAT- IT'S TAKING EVEN
MORE CARE- AND LONGER TO
ADDRESSTHEIR ISSUES- WE'VE
SEEN A- WE ACTUALLY ACT CONSULT
ON OUR MEDICAL- INPATIENT UNIT-
AND ART PSYCHOLOGY CONSOLES
OVER THIS PAST YEAR. HAVE
INCREASED BY A 100% OF OUR
CHILDREN WHO HAD- WE MADE A
SUICIDE ATTEMPT SERIOUS ENOUGH
TO REQUIRE HOSPITALIZATION. AND
ARE EATING DISORDERS HAVE HAVE
SKYROCKETED I IN THE YEAR PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC WE-
HOSPITALIZED SIXTY PATIENTS FOR
MEDICAL STABILIZATION FOR AN
EATING DISORDER- THIS LAST
FISCAL YEAR SO. JULY THREE
THROUGH JUNE OF THIS YEAR WE
HOSPITALIZED A HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN PATIENTS OPT FOR
CARE SO YOU CAN SEE THAT'S A
MASSIVE INCREASE- I THINK THE
OTHER QUESTION WE ASK AND I
KNOW DOCTOR JOHN I JUST WERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO ABOUT HOW LONG WILL
THESE ATTACKS LAST BECAUSE I
THINK THERE IS THAT. THAT SORT
OF. SENSE OF HOPEFULNESS THAT.
MAYBE IF THIS GETS ALL OVER AND
WE GET KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL ALL
THE MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS WILL
WILL LEAVE. AND I. I'M A LITTLE
WORRIED- AS I KNOW DOCTOR CHAO
IS AS WELL- AND I KNOW THAT I
MISTER HOLTZMAN TO. IS WITH THE
WITH THE LITERATURE ON
DISASTERS WHICH ARE MUCH MORE
CRIME LIMITED VOCAL- EVENTS
THAN WHAT WE'VE HAD WITH THE
PANDEMIC. CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THE LAST FOR.
THREE TO FIVE YEARS. AFTER THE
EVENTS HAS HAS FINISHED AND
WE'VE SEEN AS INCREASES IN.
DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND POST
TRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER. IN
THESE OTHER- DISASTERS- AND
WE'VE SEEN SOMETHING SIMILAR
WITH H. ONE N. ONE AND- NOT
SARS AT SO. I THINK WE HAVE TO
PLAN FOR THIS IS NOT A SHORT
TERM PROBLEM. AT THIS ELEVATED
RISK OF THE LONG TERM PROBLEM
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
THINK ABOUT. HOW DO WE TREAT
OUR CHILDREN. S. B. E. R. R.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN NETWORKS SILVA
AS WELL AS THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAD ASKED US. ARE WE
COLLABORATING AND I DO THINK
ONE OF THE WONDERFUL THINGS
ABOUT ORANGE COUNTY. IS THAT
REAL SENSE THAT WE MUST COME
TOGETHER AND WORK TOGETHER AND
I THINK YOU KNOW ALL ALL OF US
ON THE PANEL OR LIKE- YOU'LL-
TALK WITH YOU- THERE IS THAT
GREAT SENSE OF COLLABORATION
WHICH I THINK WILL ALLOW US.
HAS ALLOWED US TO MAKE THE
STRIDES WE HAVE- AND WILL ALLOW
US TO CONTINUE TO MAKE STRIDES
UNDER YOU KNOW DOCTOR CHAO'S
LEADERSHIP AND OTHERS- IN
ORANGE COUNTY. SO WE DO
COLLABORATE VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH CARE
AGENCY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. OUT
WITH HOW OPTIMA WITH THE WHILE
SYSTEM OF CARE TASK FORCE-
BRINGS TOGETHER- PEOPLE FROM
ABROAD FOR A WIDE VARIETY OF
PLACES THAT- ARE LOOKING. AT
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES- INCLUDING THIS THE
FAITH BASED COMMUNITY AS WELL
AS- HOSPITALS AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY AGENCIES SOCIAL
SERVICE SERVICES AGENCY- ARE
ORANGE COUNTY. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DISCUSS THESE KIND
AND THE **** YOU KNOW WE
CONTINUED. EXPAND COOPER AND
THAT IS THE WAY IF THINK OF.
PART OF THE PANDEMIC WE HAD A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND KIDS WE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
WE CAN ONLY DO THAT TOGETHER NO
ONE ENTITY CAN DO IT A LOT- I
JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU SOME GOOD
NEWS BECAUSE I KNOW ALL OF THAT
CAN BE KIND OF A DOWNER ABOUT.
WHAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON OF WHAT
HAVE WE BEEN DOING. A LOT OF
THIS WITH SUPPORT OF BOTH CAL
OPTIMA AND THE ORANGE COUNTY.
HEALTH CARE AGENCY UP WE'VE
DONE SOME PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION LAST YEAR WE GET
OVER A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE. I
TRAINING WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
REGENE- ALMOST EIGHTY SEVEN
HUNDRED RESIDENTS IN ORANGE
COUNTY. UP TO THAT POINT OF HOW
DO WE LET PEOPLE KNOW. WHAT'S
GOING ON BACK HI MR HOLTZMAN'S
POINTS. OUT WE DID BEGIN
SERVICES AT MATER DEI HIGH
SCHOOL SO WE WERE OUT THERE-
DEVELOPING SORT OF A WELLNESS
CULTURE AND- AND PREVENTION
SERVICES. WE HAVE A
CONSULTATION LINE FOR
PEDIATRICIANS AND SCHOOLS THAT-
WHEN PEDIATRICIANS ARE
CONFRONTED WITH A CHILD IN
THEIR CLINIC AND THEY'RE LIKE.
QUITE KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH THEM
THEY CAN CALL US THEY CAN TALK
TO OUR CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRIST IF THEY'RE GONNA
START MEDICATION. OR TALK WITH
ONE OF OUR SOCIAL WORKERS ABOUT
RESOURCES OR TREATMENT. WE ALSO
WHICH I THINK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT EFFORT- AND THROUGH
THE SUPPORT OF PELLATT. ABBVIE
CAL OPTIMA WE- HAVE INTEGRATED
PSYCHOLOGIST INTO OUR
PEDIATRICIANS OFFICES- SERVING
A LARGE- MEDICAID POPULATION
WHICH ALLOW WITH ALLOWS US TO
IDENTIFY CHILDREN EARLIER
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING IT AT
REGULAR SCREENINGS. AND WHAT WE
SEE IS A TREMENDOUSLY GREATER
UPTAKE AND SERVICES BECAUSE
IT'S BEING PROVIDED BY A
TRUSTED PROVIDER- AND LAST YEAR
WE STARTED. THIS PROCESS IN
OCTOBER- OF LAST YEAR AND- FROM
OCTOBER TO JUNE WE SERVED OVER
ELEVEN HUNDRED FAMILIES- IN OUR
FIRST YEAR OF OPERATION.
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- IN TERMS OF JUST TO
KEEP YOUR SERVICES ARE
INPATIENT MENTAL HEALTH CENTER
I JUST WANT TO MENTION- IT.
JUST AS YOU WANT IT SAY WHAT
ARE SOME THINGS WERE LEADING
THE WAY ON AN ORANGE COUNTY-
MANY ARE PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT
UNITS- HAVE ABOUT A 33% RATE OF
RETURN OF RESTRAINTS USED ON
KIDS WHEN THEY'RE HOSPITALIZED.
DUE TO JUST- WHAT A LOT OF
REACH IT'S TO IT'S- COMPLEX WE
NEED- HAVE REALLY INVESTED IN-
BOTH THE ENVIRONMENT AS WELL AS
TRAINING OUR GROUP. ARE
STRAIGHT RATE IS LESS THAN ONE
PERCENTAGE POINT ONE PERCENT-
AND OUR CHEMICAL RESTRAINTS ARE
ZERO PERCENT- OUR INTENSIVE
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM- ACTUALLY IS
A PROGRAM THAT WORKS IT
PROVIDES VERY INTENSIVE
SERVICES. AND IN THE SIX MONTHS
FOLLOWING UP PETER ALL CHILDREN
WHO WERE AT RISK. OF BEING
HOSPITALIZED FOR PSYCHIATRIC
REASONS OR HAD JUST BEEN
DISCHARGED TO MISTER HOLTZMAN
POINT OF HEY WHEN WE DISTRACT
YOU FROM AN INPATIENT UNIT WHAT
IS THE WRAP AROUND WHAT IS THE
SERVICE YOU GET. THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE THINGS IS THAT INTENSIVE
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM WHERE. KIDS
COME FOUR DAYS A WEEK FOR THREE
HOURS AT A TIME- IN THE SIX
MONTHS AFTER KIDS GRADUATE FROM
THE PROGRAM WE'VE SEEN LESS
THAN 1% OF THEM GET RE ADMITTED
TO THE PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL SO
PROGRAM THAT WORKS. AND ALSO TO
THE POINT OF WRAPAROUND
SERVICES ARE FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIP- THAT WORKS WITH
KIDS WITH MEDICAL DISORDERS AND
PSYCHIATRIC DISORDERS- WE'VE
SEEN SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN
MENTAL HEALTH SYMPTOMS
PARTICULARLY IN EATING
DISORDERS- AND WE'VE HAD SOME
GOOD SUCCESS THERE SO THERE ARE
PROGRAMS OUT THERE. THAT'S JUST
A SMALL SNAPSHOT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING THE CHOCOLATE
WONDERFUL PROGRAMS HAPPENING
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY- SO THERE
IS GOOD NEWS IN ALL OF THIS. IN
TERMS OF NEEDS FOR THE
COMMUNITY THE I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS-
WE DO HAVE A NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
OUTPATIENT CARE- I KNOW WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THERE'S
MONEY- GOING TO CHILDREN'S.
HEALTH CARE AT CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR SCHOOL-
I THINK THAT IDEA OF WHAT'S-
WHERE WHERE WHERE KIDS ARE AND
LET'S BE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
HIGH ENOUGH LEVEL OF CARE
AVAILABLE- I THINK OF A VERY
IMPORTANT PART FOR THAT MONEY
TO COME TO ORANGE COUNTY AND
BEAT. RB SPENCER- IN IN THAT
WAY AND EXPANDING THOSE
OUTPATIENT CARE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT COLLABORATION WITH
PEDIATRICIANS. WERE NEVER GONNA
HAVE ENOUGH CHILD AN ADULT
ESSENCE LIKE HYATT. OUT WE ONLY
HAVE THOUSAND IN THE ENTIRE- SO
IT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO RAMP
UP BUT WE CAN. LEVERAGE OUR
PEDIATRICIANS IF THEY HAVE
SUPPORT AND CARE SO. I'M
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT THOSE
KINDS OF CONSULTATION LINES OUT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT-
UNFORTUNATELY INTENSIVE
OUTPATIENT PROGRAMS- ARE NOT.
PAID FOR BY MEDICAID HOW AT
THIS POINT IN TIME- IT SO I
THINK IF WE COULD EXPAND THE
SERVICES- TO INCLUDE I. THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CHILDREN WITH
MEDICAL OR DISSIPATE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS WHICH WE KNOW OUR
SUCCESSFUL- AND I THINK WE
COULD USE SOME OF THE MONEY
THAT'S COMING OUT FOR EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS. TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES ARE ACROSS THE
COMMUNITY OPT FOR THAT. PORTION
OF KIDS WHO NEED IT I'M AND
THEN OUR COLLABORATION WITH
SCHOOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
THAT MONEY'S GOING INTO THE
SCHOOLS. FOR MENTAL HEALTH THAT
THAT THERE IS ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE BASED OUT WORK- AND
THINGS THAT WE KNOW WORK RATHER
THAN MONEY GOING- AND BEING
SPENT ON THINGS THAT THAT
PERHAPS WILL BE A SUCCESSFUL. I
SO APPRECIATE YOU- EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION AND- YOUR UPBRINGING
AT BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. TO THE FOREFRONT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
DOCTOR HEATHER WHO SEE- I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET AND
SPEAK WITH YOUR TEAM ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS NOW AND ALSO TOUR THE
HOSPITAL. AND I JUST WANT TO
MAKE NOTE OF SOME OF THE DATA
THAT YOU SHARED WHICH IS- IT IS
STARK WHEN WE LOOK AT EACH
STUDENTS RETURNING TO SCHOOL WE
LOOK AT SOME OF THE THINGS.
THAT THEY'VE ENDURED- NOT JUST
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC BUT IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS WHETHER IT'S
ON CAMPUS- SHOOTINGS WHETHER
IT'S- YOU SOME OF THE VERY
BASIC THINGS THAT WE DON'T EVEN
TALK ABOUT ANYMORE. BUT THAT
ARE WE KNOW WERE VERY TRAUMATIC
THE LIKE DIVORCE AND YET WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING STILL ECHOES THE
FORMER SPEAKERS. WHICH IS THAT
IF WE CAN GET TO THESE YOUNG
INDIVIDUALS EARLY AND HAVE
THESE INTERVENTIONS OR HAVE THE
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. WE'RE GOING TO
BE LESS LIKELY TO SEE THIS
TRANSLATE INTO. MAJOR CONCERNS
AS ADULTS SO I'M ALWAYS VERY
INTERESTED IN TALKING ABOUT
THAT EARLY INTERVENTIONS
TALKING ABOUT. HOW DO WE- TRY
TO PREVENT SOME OF THE EARLY
ISSUES WE MIGHT SEE AND AGAIN
WORKING WITH OUR EDUCATORS I
THINK IS VITAL. I'M REALLY
PROUD THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING OUR MYSELF ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AND THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE. TO WORK
TOWARD SOME LEGISLATION THAT
WILL SAY- LET'S MAKE SURE WE
HAVE EARLIER CONNECTIONS WITH
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
STUDENTS WHO NEED. MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT OF COURSE WITH
PARENT SUPPORT. I HAVE NOT IN
LIEU OF PARENTS BUT WITH
PARENTS SUPPORT. I WAS VERY
EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT ONE
PROJECT I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
OPENED IT YET. BUT I BELIEVE IT
WAS AND WHAT A PARK HIGH SCHOOL
YOU WERE GOING TO BE DOING A. A
WELLNESS ROOM IS THAT IF YOU
GIVE ME MY JOB ABOUT THAT. AND
THAT AGAIN WOULD. YES CAN YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT. YEAH WE LOVE
TO SO- ARE- POPULATION HEALTH
GROUP HAS- WORKED WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT OF
EDUCATION- AT ISSUE- CREATE
WHAT WE CALL WELL SPACES SO
IT'S WORKING WITH SCHOOLS AND
WHEN A PARK HIGH SCHOOL IS
INDEED ONE OF ONE OF THE PLACES
THAT ARE PUTTING TOGETHER A
RESUME THAT IS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO HELP SUPPORT
CHILDREN'S. MENTAL HEALTH- IN
SORT OF GIVING YOU THAT THAT
SPACE THAT'S- A RESPITE FROM
SCHOOL BUT ALSO CAN TEAMS IN IT
ARE COPING SKILLS MEDICATION UP
PROMPTS- ALL SORTS OF THINGS
THAT KIND OF HELP SUPPORT
CHILDREN'S. MENTAL HEALTH AND
THE SCHOOL COMMITS TO HAVING A
FULL TIME- EMPLOYEE IN THAT
SPACE USUALLY A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR AT TO HELP THE POOR
CHILDREN AND HELP ENCOURAGE
THEM TO USE THOSE SERVICES AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT
ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES CAN- CHALKER OTHER
GROUPS HELP SUPPORT WITHIN THAT
SPACE OUT FOR THAT EARLY
INTERVENTION SO WE'RE SUPER
EXCITED ABOUT THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN PARTS OF
UPPER. OUT REMEMBERING THAT IN
POINTING THAT OUT. I DO BECAUSE
AGAIN AS AN EDUCATOR MYSELF FOR
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT ON SO MANY FRONTS
ARE ARE YOUNG VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN NINETY TODDLERS TO
ADULTS- BECAUSE OF THE RISE OF
TECHNOLOGY WHICH WE KNOW IS
ACTUALLY WHAT WE'RE USING NOW
AN IMPORTANT PART OF WHO WE ARE
AND HOW WE OPERATE. BUT IT IS A
VERY LOUD NOISE WHEN KIDS ARE
USING IT WITHOUT ANY CONTROLS
WE KNOW THAT THE LIGHTS ARE FOR
US YOUNG KIDS OR FALLING ASLEEP
WITH DEVICES IN THEIR HANDS. UP
ON SOCIAL MEDIA FOR YOUNG GIRLS
SEEN IMAGES THOUSANDS OF THEM
BY THE TIME THEY'RE TEN AND
TWELVE HAS LED TO SOME OF THESE
EATING DOES DISORDERS SO HAVING
SPACES ON CAMPUSES OR WITHIN
GROUPS THAT THEY CAN GO TO KIND
OF MOVE AWAY FROM SOME OF THAT
JUST CHATTERING NOISE. I THINK
IS GOING TO START TO PUT THE
BACK INTO SPACE WHERE THEY CAN
UP CALM THE BRAIN DOWN IF YOU
WANT TO SAY THAT WE ALL KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS TO US AS ADULTS.
AND WE'VE SEEN THIS PLAY OUT
WHERE WERE WHETHER IT'S- NEW
SOURCES SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS THAT
WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE GET
ANGRIER AND ANGRIER AND
ANGRIER. AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE A
BALLOON WE'VE SEEN- RESPONSES
OF HATE AND SOME OF ITS BECAUSE
SO MUCH OF THE IMOGENE WERE
SEEN. IT REALLY IS PUSHING
PEOPLE TO A POINT OF- OF DOING
THINGS THEY MAY NEVER HAVE
THOUGHT OF DONE IN THE PAST BUT
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE TRUCK COSTS
BUT OF AN ORANGE COUNTY WE KNOW
YOU'RE PART OF THE SOLUTION AND
WE THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU. OKAY UP SO SOME OF
YOU MIGHT NOTICE THAT I'M
TALKING WITH OUR PANELISTS WE
DO HAVE A COMMITTEE FOR ORANGE
COUNTY A SELECT COMMITTEE ON
HOMELESSNESS MY- SELECT GROUP
PARTICIPANTS WEREN'T ABLE TO
MAKE IT I WILL SPEAK UP ON
THEIR BEHALF OF FRIDAY IN
SACRAMENTO IS A WHO IS A VERY
QUIET DAY AND MANY TIMES- ARE
PARTICIPANTS ON THIS COMMITTEE-
ARE ALREADY ENGAGED IN THEIR
DISTRICTS BUT OUR OTHER MEMBERS
INCLUDE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LAURIE DAVIS FROM ORANGE COUNTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JANET NGUYEN
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COUNTY PETRIE-NORRIS
FROM ORANGE COUNTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ FROM
THE CHINO AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BE GOT GAL SANTIAGO FROM LOS
ANGELES SO IF YOU FEEL LIKE I'M
DOING A LOT OF TALKING IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE OF THE ONLY ONE
HERE PARTICIPATING- BUT I KNOW
SOME OF THEIR TEAMS ARE ARE
LISTENING IN AS WELL AS MANY
OTHER ELECTED TO AN ORANGE
COUNTY FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING AS A LOCAL
ELECTED COUNTY OR EVEN OTHERS
FROM OUR A HOUSING. FOR OUR
HOMELESS COMMUNITY OR ADVOCATES
I THINK YOU BECAUSE AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED NONE OF US ARE GOING
TO SOLVE SOLVE THIS ISSUE
INDIVIDUALLY AND WE NEED
COALITIONS IN COLOR
COLLABORATIONS TO DO THE VERY
BEST WE CAN IN ORANGE COUNTY
OUR SECOND PANDA PANEL IS IN
AGAIN THANK YOU TO OUR AMAZING
SPEAKERS ON OUR FIRST PANEL OUR
SECOND PANEL IS GOING TO NOW-
WHAT I'M GOING TO WELCOME IN
AND DO IN REDUCE THEM AND THIS
NEXT PANEL WOULD BE FOCUSING ON
MENTAL HEALTH AND HOMELESSNESS.
THROUGH INTEGRATED COMMUNITY.
PARTNERSHIPS AND PROGRAMS. AND
JUST TO SET THE STATE FOR
ORANGE COUNTY. SOME OF. OUR
LISTENERS MIGHT KNOW THAT I
HAVE BEEN NOT ONLY A BULLDOG-
AND SOME MIGHT CALL ME OTHER
NAME IS AN ORANGE COUNTY
RELATED HOMELESS AND HOUSING-
BUT- I'M ALSO. THANKFUL FOR
WHAT WE HAVE DONE SO EVEN
THOUGH HAS BEEN SAID I'M VERY
PROUD OF WHAT WE'VE DONE
THERE'S MORE TO DO. KNOW THAT I
DO APPRECIATE- THE INDIVIDUALS
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE GROUPS
THAT ARE LEADING THIS EVERITT
IN ORANGE COUNTY TO HOUSE THOSE
THAT. ARE NOT HOUSED BUT ALSO
TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS WE KNOW
THAT PREVENTION IS ONE OF THE
MAIN FACTORS. IN REDUCING
HOMELESSNESS SO WHETHER IT'S-
PARISHES OR CHURCHES. OR
INDIVIDUAL NON PROFITS THAT ARE
ABLE TO HELP FAMILIES WITH
RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO STAY IN
APARTMENT VERSES BEING. EVICTED
WHETHER IT'S- GRANTS AND FUNDS
THAT PEOPLE ARE APPLYING FOR TO
HELP IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES THAT'S ALL MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN ORANGE COUNTY.
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO NOW IS
MOVE TO A MODEL THAT I HAVE
BEEN OUT TO VISIT AS A NEW
MODEL AND ORANGE COUNTY IT IS
ACTUALLY CALLED BE WELL ORANGE
COUNTY. THEY HAVE- IN A VERY
EXCITING DAY FOR THEM- WILL BE
WALL WELCOMING MR MARSHALL
MONCRIEF WHO IS THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WHEN A LET
HIM OUTLINED NOT ONLY WHAT BE
WELL DOES BUT I KNOW THAT. IN
THE OTHER PART SOUTH COUNTY
IRVINE I BELIEVE THEY ARE GOING
TO BE. CELEBRATING STATE FUNDS
THAT HAVE COME IN TO BUILD A
SECOND MODEL OF BE WELL BUT FOR
TODAY LET'S WELCOME MR MARSHALL
MONCRIEF. HI ASSEMBLY WOMAN
KIRK SILVA- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WANT TO ECHO THE FIRST
PANEL- REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ACROSS THESE TOPICS. AND
PARTICULARLY THIS THIS TOPIC-
FOR THIS OUR SECOND PANEL ON
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS- IT REALLY STRIKES
AT THE CORE OF WHAT BE WELL
ORANGE COUNTY IS ABOUT AND IN
FACT I GOT- SUCH A KICK AND A
BIG SMILE OUT OF SEEING ALL THE
PEOPLE. ARE LISTED- ACROSS THE
PANELS TODAY BECAUSE ALL OF
THEM HAVE BEEN A PART OF THAT
ARE PART OF THE LEADERS IN BE
WELL ORANGE COUNTY AND SO MANY
OF THEM COULD SPEAK ON THE
TOPIC OF BE WELL- JUST LIKE I
COULD STILL- HONORED TO TAKE A
MINUTE- TO TALK ABOUT IT. AND
THEN I WANT TO SHIFT GEARS AND
TALK ABOUT- THE TOPIC AT HAND
WHICH IS INTEGRATEDCOMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AS IT APPLIES TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND HOMELESSNESS
SPECIFICALLY AND I'D LIKE TO
ECHO A COUPLE OF THINGS. THAT
MISTER HOLD SPEND A DOCTOR CHAO
HIGHLIGHTED. AND THEN FOLLOW
HEATHER'S LEAD IN IDENTIFYING A
COUPLE OF NEEDS- IN THE
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THAT. SO JUST TO SET SOME
CONTEXT- BE WELL ORANGE COUNTY-
IS AN EFFORT LED BY EVERYBODY-
HERE TODAY- TRYING TO BRING
TOGETHER THE COMMUNITY INTO ONE
UNIFIED EFFORT- IDENTIFYING
THAT WE HAVE A LOT. OF REALLY
GREAT SERVICES A LOT OF REALLY
GREAT PROGRAMS IN ORANGE COUNTY
BUT HISTORICALLY THEY HAVE
OPERATED IN SILOS AND
FRAGMENTATION IS AS BIG A
CHALLENGE AS THE OLDEST SERVICE
THEMSELVES. FRAGMENTATION OF
OUR SYSTEM IS AS BIG A
CHALLENGE AS THE OLDER SYSTEMS
BUT NONE CELLS AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY'LL BE WELL HAS. BEEN
AIMING TO SOLVE FOR. SO YEARS A-
OF US- ON THE MULTIPLE PANELS
TODAY GOT TOGETHER TO SAY WE
CAN DO BETTER IF WE DO THINGS
TOGETHER AND WE ORGANIZED
OURSELVES AROUND MULTIPLE
RESULT AREAS. AND STREAMS OF
ACTION AND LIKE YOU NOTED
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- WE HAVE NOW
OPENED OUR FIRST CAMPUS OF
CARE- IN ORANGE COUNTY WHICH IS
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND. BY WAY
OF COLLABORATION THROUGH THE
ORANGE COUNTY HEALTH CARE
AGENCY. ALABAMA AND MANY OF THE
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS- ALL WHILE
PARTICIPATING TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. BECAUSE THEY ALL CAME
TOGETHER TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN-
THE CAMPUS IS AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE IN A UNIQUE WAY THAT'S
EXHAUSTING TO THEIR PAYER
STATUS. AND FOCUSED MOSTLY ON
THEIR CLINICAL LEAD. SO THE
FIRST THREE PATIENTS THAT CAME
THROUGH THE CAMPUS OF WHEN WE
OPENED IN JANUARY. THE FIRST
ONE WAS A HOMELESS GENTLEMAN
UNFUNDED AND ANY ABBREVIATED
AND WE WERE ABLE TO BRING HIM
AND GET HIM STABILIZE CONNECTED
TO CARE. AND AND RAP RAP A HUG
OF SUPPORT AROUND. THE SECOND
PATIENT. WAS A MEDICAID A YOUNG
LADY- WHO WAS STRUGGLING WITH
SUICIDAL IDEATION AND WAS IN AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT NOT
GETTING GOOD CARE WE WERE ABLE
TO- MEDICALLY STABILIZE HER AND
GET HER OVER TO THE CAMPUS IN
UNDER THIRTY MINUTES. AND THERE
WE WERE ABLE TO STABILIZE GET
HER BACK HOME AND TO HELP
PATIENTS PROGRAM AND COMMUNITY.
AND THE THIRD PATIENT WAS- BUT
COMMERCIALLY INSURED YOUNG MAN
TWENTY TWO HAVING HIS FIRST
PSYCHOTIC BREAK OVER AT ANOTHER
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT- BECAUSE
WE HAD ALREADY TRAINED THAT E.
R. WE WERE ABLE TO MEDICALLY
CLEAR HIM. VERY QUICKLY GET
OVER TO THE CAMPUS AND HIS
FIRST WORDS UPON ARRIVAL WORK
WELL I THINK I COULD BREATHE.
SO EVEN IN THE MIDST OF A FIRST
PSYCHIATRIC BREAK NEW THE
DIFFERENCE OF THE ENVIRONMENT
HE WAS IN AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. VERSUS THE
ENVIRONMENT OF THIS- HIGH
QUALITY CLINICAL CARE FACILITY
AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET HIM
INTO THE CARE NEEDED. THE
REASON I HIGHLIGHT THOSE THOSE
THREE PATIENTS- IS BECAUSE IT
SPEAKS TO WHAT'S POSSIBLE WITH
COLLABORATION. SO ONE OF THE
HOSPITALS WOULD HAVE A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME TREATING ALL
THREE OF THOSE PEOPLE ACROSS
ALL THREE OF THOSE DIFFERENT
HAIR TYPES. ALL THREE OF THOSE
DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHICS
SITUATIONS AND ALL THREE OF
THOSE CLINICAL PRESENTATIONS.
BUT BECAUSE THE COUNTY ALABAMA
THE HOSPITAL'S ALL DID THIS
TOGETHER WE WERE ABLE TO CARE
FOR ALL THREE OF THOSE PEOPLE
IN THE SAME PLACE NO QUESTIONS
ASKED BRING THEM IN AND WRAPPED
A HOPELESS SUPPORT AROUND. SO
TO ME THAT START SPEAKING TO
THE TOPIC THAT YOU'VE LAID OUT
FOR US TODAY. OF THE INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS. AND AND
THE NECESSITY OF BRINGING
COMMUNITY AND A COMMUNITY OF
CARE PROVIDERS BETTER TOGETHER
TO CREATE SYSTEMS OF CARE THAT
ARE MORE INTEGRATED AND
HOLISTIC. AND I REALLY LIKED-
MR HOLTZMAN'S COMMENTS ON THAT
HOLISTIC INTEGRATED CONTINUUM'S.
OF CARE AND THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
ALL RIGHT A HIGHLIGHT A LITTLE-
PIECE AT. IN OUR SYSTEM NOW AND
THAT IS WE HAVE FRAGMENTATION
WITHIN THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
ITSELF. WE HAVE FRAGMENTATION
WITHIN THE HOMELESS SERVICES
SOLUTION ITSELF. AND BURN
REGRETTABLY OFTENTIMES THE
TUESDAY BROWN'S- POOR ATTEMPTS
AT SYSTEMS ARE NOT INTEGRATED
NEARLY ENOUGH- THE FUNDING
STREAMS OFTENTIMES KEEP
SEPARATE EFFORTS FUNDING
STREAMS OFTENTIMES CREATE
COMPETITION AND FRAGMENTATION
OF INSTEAD OF COLLABORATION AND
CONNECTIVITY AND SO THERE'S
SOME REAL OPPORTUNITY THERE- IN
THE LAST- IN THE LAST PLANE
PLANE CAL- OR AT LEAST FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN POINT IN TIME
COUNT I THAT I HAVE IN FRONT OF
ME- WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ENTERED
HOMELESSNESS- AT THAT POINT IN
TIME COUNT IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
IT WAS UP ROUGHLY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE ENTERED INTO
HOMELESSNESS. AND WHEN WE LOOK
AT WHO EXITED HOMELESSNESS
INTO- GOING BACK HOME OR INTO
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT WAS
AROUND ROUGHLY SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED. SO MUCH MORE GOING
INTO HOMELESSNESS THEN WE HAD
GOING OUT OF HOMELESSNESS. AND
THE OTHER THING I THINK TO NOTE
IS THAT AMONG THOSE GOING INTO
HOMELESSNESS ONLY 40%
IDENTIFIED ECONOMIC REASONS. SO
IF WE HAVE 60% OF THE DRIVERS
AND THE HOMELESSNESS IS MENTAL
HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE AND THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE GOING INTO
HOMELESSNESS FAR OUTSTRIPPING
THE NUMBER THAT ARE EXITING
HOMELESSNESS AND WE'VE GOT SOME
REAL NEEDS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
BETTER WEAVE TOGETHER THE
SYSTEM OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE
AND THE SYSTEM OF HOMELESS
SERVICE SOLUTIONS AND WE'RE
GONNA NEED A WHOLE COMMUNITY
EFFORT TO PULL THAT OFF-
OBVIOUSLY. NOT EVERYBODY THAT
IS HOMELESS IS MENTALLY ILL AND
NOT EVERYBODY WAS MENTALLY ILL
IS OMELESS- BUT THE NUMBERS
ARE- ARE STRONG ENOUGH SUCH
THAT WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
OVERLAP. BUT WE'VE GOT TO GET
REAL INTENTIONAL ABOUT BRINGING
THESE SYSTEMS TOGETHER. SO A
COUPLE OF- OF SORT OF SPECIFIC
NEEDS I THINK- AGAIN FOLLOWING
HEATHER'S LEAD I THINK WE HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
LOOKING AT THAT STATE FUNDING.
OF THAT OFTENTIMES RUNS THROUGH
A COUNTY CHANNEL WE HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO USE THAT
FUNDING- TO INCENTIVIZE
COLLABORATION AND CONNECTIVITY
AND INTEGRATION. BECAUSE
INADVERTENTLY SOMETIMES THOSE
FUNDING STREAMS DR COMPETITION
AND FRAGMENTATION- AMONGST A
GROUP OF CARE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
LARGELY- BY DNA DESIGN LOOKING
FOR COLLABORATION AND
CONNECTIVITY- BUT OFTENTIMES
FUNDING STREAMS BECAUSE
COMPETITION AND THAT
SEPARATION. SO I WOULD CALL
THAT OUT AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US IN CALIFORNIA AND IN ORANGE
COUNTY TO LOOK AT OUR FUNDING
STREAMS AS OPPORTUNITIES. TO
LEVERAGE- AND INCENTIVIZE
PARTNERSHIP AND INTEGRATION. OF
THE OTHER THING I JUST THAT
CAUGHT MY ATTENTION OF THAT
DOCTOR CHAO WAS COMMENTING ON
IS- THE DIFFICULTY WITH THE
ILLNESSES THEMSELVES. AND SO WE
JUST TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE SYSTEM AND THE
FRAGMENTATION THERE HOW WE
MIGHT ADDRESS SOME THINGS TO
BRING INTEGRATION BUT THEN
THERE'S THE CHALLENGES OF THE
ILLNESSES THEMSELVES. AND AND
THERE IS A STRANGE QUALITY TO
THE ILLNESSES OF SUBSTANCE USE
AND MENTAL- MENTAL ILLNESSES
WHERE IN THE PERSON SUFFERING
OFTENTIMES IS THE LAST IN LINE
TO REALIZE THE DEGREE TO WHICH
THEY'RE STRUGGLING AND
SUFFERING AND OFTENTIMES IT'S
THE ILLNESS ITSELF. THAT
PREVENTS THEM FROM ENGAGING IN
CARE ALL THE DIFFERENT THAN
OTHER MEDICAL ILLNESSES
SOMEBODY A GETS A CANCER
DIAGNOSIS TODAY THERE AT THE
FRONT OF THE LINE SAYING YES
PLEASE SIGN ME UP GET ME INTO
THE BEST CARE PROVIDER
POSSIBLE- THE PERSON STRUGGLING
WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA OR A SEVERE
ADDICTION. OFTENTIMES IT TAKES
MANY MANY MANY TIMES OF
ENGAGEMENT TO GET THEM TO SEE
THE DEVASTATION OF THEIR
ILLNESS AND AGREED TO CARE. AND
SO I JUST WANTED TO UNDERSCORE
SOMETHING DOCTOR CHANNEL
MENTIONED WITH REGARDS TO-
POLICY CHANGE IN REGULATION
CHANGE IN IT VIRTUALLY SOME OF
THE POLICIES IN PLACE THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO PROTECT PEOPLES-
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS WHICH IS
CLEARLY A VERY IMPORTANT THING.
CAN ALSO INADVERTENTLY
INTERFERE WITH A COMMUNITY OF
CARE PROVIDERS BEING ABLE TO DO
WHAT'S CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE
FOR A PERSON IN NEED- OF A
STORY THAT- THAT THAT STRUCK ME
ECENTLY AND I- HERE THESE
STORIES ALL THE TIME- EVERYDAY
OF MY LIFE IN FACT- A FAMILY
MEMBER CALLED ME A FEW WEEKS
AGO. BECAUSE THERE- A TEENAGER
WAS- PSYCHOTIC IN THE PARK-
pHAD BEEN LIVING IN THE BUSHES
IN THE PARK- FOR MANY DAYS- THE
CARE PROVIDER TEAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE COMMUNITY.
WENT OUT AND WENT AND GAVE EACH
THE YOUNG MAN- HE WAS A TO PULL
THE ENOUGH TO SAY OH NO I'M
GONNA GO GET A SANDWICH AND
THAT'S WHERE I'M GONNA SHOWER
UP AND- HE WAS ABLE TO HOLD IT
TOGETHER FOR THE SIXTY SECOND.
NINETY SECOND INTERACTION-
SUFFICIENT TO SAY THERE'S NO
CRITERIA TO INTERVENE ON THIS
PERSON AGAINST THEIR WILL- THE
YOUNG MAN DIED- NOT LONG AFTER
THAT- TO SUICIDE. SO I THINK
THERE IS- SOMETHING HERE ON THE
POLICY SIDE WITH THE ILLNESSES
THEMSELVES. THAT- PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY- FOR US TO
INTERVENE BETTER AND- AND
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE FOLKS-
WHEN IT COMES TO HOMELESSNESS-
WE NOW KNOW 60% OF THEM OUT
THERE AT LEAST AT THE TWENTY
NINETEEN POINT TIME COUNT. ARE
THERE DRIVEN BY SUBSTANCE USE.
AND MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS. SO
I'LL STOP THERE- AGAIN MUCH
APPRECIATION FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK SILVA AND-
WE ARE OUR BROTHERS SISTERS IN
ARMS HERE BECAUSE WE KNOW YOUR
PERSONAL PASSION WE SHARE IT
WITH YOU. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU MR
MARSHALL- MONCRIEF- FOR THAT
VERY- EXTENSIVE REMARKS ABOUT
NOT ONLY WHAT YOU SEE THAT
WE'RE DOING WELL BUT ALSO. AS
YOU SAID FRAGMENTATION IN THE
SYSTEM I TOO HAVE SEEN THAT NOT
ONLY FIRSTHAND BUT ALSO AS
SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS AN AREA
ALL TOO OFTEN BECAUSE OF THE
SILOS AND BY THE WAY I WILL
REMARK THAT THERE IS MUCH WORK.
GOING ON YOU YOU N. B. WELL AND
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE
WHICH IS AN EXTENSIVE GROUP I
BELIEVE AT ONE POINT YOU HAD
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY PEOPLE ON
YOUR- KIND OF ADVISORY
COMMITTEE- VERY. IS THAT
CORRECT OR WELL YEAH THERE'S-
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE THAT
ARE NOW ACTIVELY INVOLVED AND
BE WELL ORANGE COUNTY AT OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS OUT
OF TOUCH INTO IT VARIOUS
POINTS. AND SO- WE HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO WE HAVE A LOT OF
POTHOLES WE'RE GOING TO STEP
IN- BUT IT IS SUCCEEDING IN
CREATING A SPACE WHERE
EVERYBODY CAN COME TOGETHER AND
LANDED THEIR PARTICULAR SKILLS
AND TALENTS AND RESOURCES. IN
THE SAME SWIM LANE AND AGAIN I
WANT TO CALL OUT EVERY SINGLE
PERSON ON YOUR PANELS TODAY OUR
LEADERS WITHIN THAT SPACE AND
SO THEY COULD SPEAK TO THIS AS
MUCH AS ME- AND- AND SO WE
THINK ORANGE COUNTY. IS
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO SERVE AS
A MODEL FOR THE STATE AND- AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF LEADERSHIP
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY WHO ARE
INNOVATIVE. AND THEIR
COURAGEOUS AND READY TO MAKE
THE CHANGES NEEDED. TO UNIFY A
SYSTEM AND DO SOMETHING
TRANSFORMATIONAL ORANGE COUNTY
AND FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU ANYONE
INDEED YOU HAVE BY OPENING UP
THE FIRST OF BE WELL THE ORANGE
COUNTY BUT ALSO. TO NOTE IT IS
A PART OF THE PUZZLE WE NEED
ADDITIONAL. B. WELLS I KNOW IN
THE CASE. WE WOULD HAVE FOR OF
THEM THAT WOULD TOUCH NOT ONLY-
CENTRAL SOUTH NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY- THAT BEING SAID EVERY
STEP FORWARD IS A STEP TO
CELEBRATE. ONE OF THE THINGS
THOUGH I'VE WORKED ON AS THE
STATE AS FAR AS POLICY HAS BEEN.
WHAT YOU AND OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED WHERE IS IF IN
INDIVIDUAL TRIES TO ATTAIN THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND YET
THEY HAVE AN ADDICTION- THE LAW
WAS UNCLEAR OF CAN. MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDS BE USED FOR CO
OCCURRING CONDITIONS AND IN
FACT MY BILL LAST YEAR THAT WAS
SIGNED CLARIFIED. THAT YES IF
SOMEBODY'S EXPERIENCING NOT
ONLY ADDICTION BUT MENTAL
HEALTH THEY CAN BE TREATED I
AND BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE HAVE
BEEN POINTS WHERE IF YOU'RE
HAVE AN ADDICTION NO YOU NEED
TO COME TO US BUT IF YOU HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH YOU NEED TO GO
OVER THERE. AND THAT IS AN
EXTREMELY A DIFFICULT A
SCENARIO FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING AND THEN IF YOU
ADD ON TO THAT SOMETIMES
ANOTHER OCCURRING A CONDITION
WHICH COULD BE A PHYSICAL
CONDITION SOME PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING THREE OCCURRING
CONDITIONS AT THE SAME TIME.
AND THEN ADD EVEN MORE TO THAT
WITH WHICH MA BE VERY LITTLE
RESOURCES TO GET AROUND THE
COUNTY FROM TRANSPORTATION- TO
VERY LITTLE RESOURCES FROM
ACTUALLY HAVING- DOLLARS IN
THEIR POCKET POCKET TO HOP ON A
BUS TO GET A NEW WORD TO GET TO
THESE APPOINTMENTS. SO WHEN
WEEKEND HOUSE SOME OF THESE
SERVICES UNDER ONE UMBRELLA IN
ONE BUILDING EVEN MAKE THESE
APPOINTMENTS THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING FROM ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER
BUT NOW EVEN WITH IF ANYTHING
IS A SILVER LINING IS A THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC IS THESE VIRTUAL
OPPORTUNITIES HAVING PEOPLE
POSSIBLY BEING ABLE TO ATTEND-
THERAPY. OR A SESSION THAT
COULD HELP A VIRTUALLY ACT-
WHETHER IT'S EVEN THE HOUSING
PLACE THAT THEY'RE AT SO
THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO TRAVEL
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY YEP TO
APPOINTMENT TO APPOINTMENT AND
FOR SOME OF THEM THE TOLERANCE
IS VERY LITTLE AND WE LOSE THEM
IN THAT SYSTEM- SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD. TO SEEING THAT AND
AGAIN WHEN I SEE THESE
INTEGRATED INTEGRATED SYSTEMS
OF CARE I KNOW THAT WE'RE ON
THE RIGHT TRACK- THANK YOU
MISTER MARSHALL. MONCRIEFF AND-
GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN. AND
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND OUT
NOW INTRODUCE- MISTER PAUL
LEóN I AND- MISTER PAUL LEóN
I WAS ACTUALLY SOMEBODY. THAT
WORKED FOR THE COUNTY NOW IS
WORKING WITH HIS OWN
FOUNDATION. I AND HE HAS. I
THINK TOUCH MANY MANY
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE TYPE OF
CARE HE IS PROVIDING MISTER
PAUL LEóN IS THE PRESIDENT AND
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
ILLUMINATION FOUNDATION WHICH
BY THE WAY THE CITY OF FULLER
TEN HOST. WHICH WE CALL ON A I
WILL LET HIM DESCRIBE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IN FULLERTON
WELCOME MR LEON. RIGHT GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S KIRK
SILVA AND- THE SELECTED A AND
ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES YOURSELF
THANKFUL THAT- WERE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE TODAY WITH THE
AIRLINE- I'M ACTUALLY IN ORDER
CAN ACT THE RECUPERATIVE
NAVIGATION CENTER BACK-
ASSEMBLY WHAT MAKING IT WORSE
SO INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING ME
PUSH FORWARD- PLEASE IT IS ONE
OF THE MODELS ALONG WITH THE
WELL. THAT WE REALLY. NEED AND
NEED IT FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS THAT DOCTOR CHILD MYSELF
MATT- MANY OF US TRYING TO WORK
TOWARDS AND THAT IS AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM UP HEALTHCARE
HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH DENTAL
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ALL UNDER ONE
UMBRELLA- IT'S THAT WE OPEN UP
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO.
AND IT WORKED FAR BETTER THAN
WE HAD ANTICIPATED- AND I DON'T
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS
THIS A LITTLE BIT BY. HOW THE
COMMUNITY FEELS ABOUT HAVING A
CENTER WITH IN THE END THERE
COMMUNITY AND YOU ALLUDED TO
THAT A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEM
HAVING RESERVATIONS- MENTAL
HEALTH HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING CELLS TO BE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS
COMING INTO THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HAD COLOR TEN
WERE RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
FROM A PRESCHOOL DOWN THE
STREET FROM A JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL IN HIGH SCHOOL AND A
RESIDENTIAL AREA BEHIND US AND
WE'VE BEEN HERE A YEAR AND A
HALF AND WE HAD ZERO COMPLAINTS
WE'VE ACTUALLY INTEGRATED WITH
COMMUNITY AND OUR HELP IN THAT.
SO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
THE COMMUNITY- WE ARE MODEL TO
BETTER BACK NEXT WEEK WE HAVE A
CONTINGENCY FIRM IN NEW YORK
STATE THAT'S GONNA FLY OUT AND
TAKE A TOUR TWO DAYS OUT NOT
ONLY DID THEY ASK BUT-
HOPEFULLY BE WHILE. AND SOME OF
THE MY- EXAMINER TALK. AND
DURING KOBE THERE. OF THEM OUT
THAT'S HOW WE IMPORT. WHILE
WORKING AND CATCH WHAT MODELS
COULD DO. A TO SERVE OUR MOST.
BUT WHAT I LIKE TO STRETCH WITH
YOU IS JUST. WORKING PIECE OF
WHAT WE DO AND THAT'S THAT THAT
WE WORK WITH- YOU KNOW WE CHECK
ACROSS THAT OF TWELVE HUNDRED
FIFTY AND- THAT CAME THROUGH
ARCUS. AND WORK PREDICT- THE
FEW YEARS. AND ONE THING WE-
RIGHT AWAY. THAT FIFTY EIGHT OF
THEM WERE SPM ICE SEVERE
PERSISTENT MENTAL ILLNESS- NOW
IT THEY SHOULD BE AT A FULL
SERVICE PROGRAM BUT AS YOU KNOW
THE SERVICES AND PROVIDERS ARE
SO LIMITED. THAT THEY DID HAVE
TURKEY AND RECUPERATIVE CARE
AND WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF AND
STILL ARE TAKING CARE OF A-
YOU'LL SEE THAT WITH THIS NEXT
SLIDE. THAT 81% OF THE TWELVE
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX HAVE A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS AND
55% OF THAT EIGHTY ONE PERCENT.
HAVE A SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND ARE-
SP AND LYFT DIAGNOSIS SO I
BELIEVE- BACKSTROKE ABOUT THE
CO OCCURRING. DISORDERS AND-
YOU- HI THE FACT THAT NOT ALL
WEEK WITH PEOPLE WITH SO ABUSE.
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER. BUT
MEDICAL DISORDERS THAT'S WHY
THE FACILITY THAT WERE IN IS SO
CRUCIAL BECAUSE WE CAN'T HANDLE
MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE IF SUPPORTERS
ALL RIGHT NOT. ALL IN THE SAME
PROGRAM THIS IS JUST A SLIDE
THAT JUST GOES TO SHOW THAT THE
REST- FORTIES INDIVIDUALS YOU
SEE THAT ZERO HI IT'S
COOPERATION. ARE MENTAL HEALTH
AT SCHIZOPHRENIA THERE THAT
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE PROBABLY
GOING TO BE ARTS ON REGULAR
BASIS. IT'S INSTRUMENTAL WE
CAPTURE NOT ONLY THIS DATA BUT
COST WISE- JUST TO CHERYL HOW
EFFECTIVE THIS PROGRAM IS THE
ONLY AND IN TREATING THESE
INDIVIDUALS BUT. ALSO THAT WE
ARE. J. TAXPAYERS AND IF WE THE
MONEY APPROACH LIFE HAVE THERE
ANALYTICS. WE COULD DO THAT SO
WE KNOW HOW TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE SAYS THAT HIT THAT
WATER REPORT HEY. SO AGAIN WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE BREAKDOWN I
DON'T THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
REALIZE THAT LOOK AT THE AGE
GROUP WITH THE S. THEY MADE
LAST WEEK TAKE CARE THERE IS A
22% THAT ARE. FIFTY FIVE TO
SIXTY FIVE OUR PASSAGE GROWING
POPULATION OF HOMELESS OR
SENIOR WOMEN AS A MATTER OF
FACT SOME OF OUR FACILITIES
THAT WE WANTED ORANGE COUNTY WE
HAVE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE LESS
EIGHTY YEARS ALL WE HAVE TO
MAKE IT EASIER EIGHTY FIVE
YEARS ALL. THAT LIVED IN OUR
COMMUNITY THAT WORKED THE WHOLE
TIME I HUSBANDS AND NALCOR
DEPENDENT ON US TO TAKE CARE OF
IN A SHELTER. WITH HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE. THAT'S THE NEXT.
CARESSES COMMUNITY- AGAIN I
REMEMBER TALKED ABOUT FAUCETS
EXPENSE THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
LICENSE STAFF THAT ARE NURSES
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS DOCTORS- BUT THIS GRANT
WILL SHOW YOU. A NEED FOR
CREDIT INTO THAT PROGRAM THAT
WHILE HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE WE
CHECK CHARACTER THE COST WAS
TWENTY FIVE. MILLION SIX
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND
RODWAY OF COURSE WHEN THEY'RE
IN OUR PROGRAM GATE WENT DOWN
CONSIDERABLY BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT NUMBER TO LOOK AT
HERE IS A LOOK WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THEY WENT BACK IN A
PERMANENT CAL. THAT COSTS WOULD
STILL LOWER AND IT AND APOSS
STAVING SUCH SEVENTEEN MILLION
WHICH JUST SO IT'S TWELVE
HUNDRED THE INDIVIDUALS SO WE
HAVE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT IT IS
COST EFFECTIVE AND IT IS BETTER
FOR THE CLIENTS THAT THEY CAN
RECEIVE ALL THOSE- REMEMBER
ALTHOUGH SERVICES. IN ONE
PROGRAM- EXPECT STAY WE'VE BEEN
THIS FOR TWO YEARS. AND ALLOW
WITH MANY OTHER AND COMMUNITY.
I THINK THAT- THAT MARSHALL
TALKED- THAT CONTINUE OF CARE
THAT BRIDGES TO MAKE CLOSER.
ONE AT THAT YOU KNOW THE BIG.
ITEMS AN ORANGE COUNTY LA
THROUGHOUT THE NATION'S
HOUSING. HOUSING THAT'S HEALTH
CARE AND JUST RECENTLY WHERE-
MANY AT THAT WELL I SEATS ARE
COMING DOWN THEY ARE BEGINNING
TO SEE ON THE MEDICAL INDUSTRY
IS BEGINNING TO SEE THAT
HOUSING IS HEALTHCARE. IF YOU
CAN'T TELL SOMEBODY- SUFFICIENT
WAY THAT THEY CAN'T ACCESS
HEALTH CARE SO THAT'S A HUGE
COMPONENT THAT WE'RE INVOLVED
WITH AGAIN MANY OTHERS AN
ORANGE COUNTY TO HIGHLIGHT THE
FACT THAT HOUSING IS HEALTHCARE
AND IT'S ESSENTIAL. FOR US TO
MOVE FORWARD. I ONE OF THE THAT
THAT WE EMPLOY EARLY ON- WITH
MANY OTHERS IS TO HOME BEING A
TO TEXT. WITH OUT REACH AGAIN
OF OUR CITY- BUT- FROM THE COW.
ARE WORKING AND HOW REACH. THAT
GRAHAM US SHELTERS LIKE BASS
AND WE CAN MOVE THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY. IT'S THIS. ONE OF
THE BIGELOW EXCITING THINGS
COMING I NOW COMING SACRAMENTO
IT'S KELLY WORKING WHERE. ALOT
DIMANA THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING IT
LITERACY SERVICES ADD IT IS SO
ESSENTIAL THAT- THESE FOUR
COMPONENTS THAT MANY OF US ARE
WORKING WELL. THAT THEIR
IMPLEMENTED SO THAT WE CAN
AGAIN TAKE THAT MONEY THAT'S
COMING DOWN I CAN'T STAND IT
APPEARS THAT WAY WISELY AND
TARGET TO PEOPLE THAT NEED OUR
HELP THE MOST SO. AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR AND THEIR SHARE AND STE
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO- THIS
NEXT YEAR BUT OUT OF HOGAN AND
WORKING MORE WITH- MY
COLLEAGUES AND I DON'T HAVE BIG
BOTTLES AT YOU AND THAT COULD
MAKE A HAVE SUPPORT AND- I IN
THE PAST SO THAT WE GET. RELATE
I PUT IT DOWN AND ANALYSTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
LEóN- SO WHO I'VE NOT. THE NEW
THAT IS A IT IS LEGACY TO. DO
WELL WE NEED TO DO TO GET
PEOPLE THIS AND- I THIS
IMMENSELY I WILL GO AHEAD AND
RE QUOTE WHAT YOU JUST SAID
HOUSING IS HEALTH CARE AND I
HAVE TO SAY THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME I'VE HEARD THAT TERM BUT
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE THE LAST
TIME I USE THAT TERM. BECAUSE
LAST WEEK I SPENT QUITE A BIT
WITH OUR CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION GOING TO SAINT JUDE
PROVIDENCE NOW ON FULLER TEN
TALKING TO SOME OF. THE
PROVIDERS AND AS WE KNOW WHAT
THE IMPACT WITH NOT ONLY COVERT
BUT WITH THIS POPULATION
WHETHER IT'S MENTAL MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS ADDICTION NEEDS.
THEM NOW SUPPORTING B. WELL BUT
PERHAPS IN THE FUTURE
SUPPORTING HOUSING THIS THIS
MAKES SENSE WE WANT PEOPLE WHO
NEED TO BE AN EMERGENCY ROOMS
AND IN THE HOSPITAL TO BE THERE
BUT PEOPLE WHO CAN BE TREATED.
IN OTHER TYPES OF MODELS AND
THEN EVENTUALLY GET THEM HELLO
STE SO THAT WE'RE NOT HAVING AN
ISSUE SAID- THE SERVICE PERSON
A PERSISTENT MENTAL ILLNESS AND
WE KNOW THAT WITH SOME OF OUR
DATA TRACKING SYSTEMS SOMETIMES
IT'S THE TWENTY FIVE TO FIFTY
PEOPLE. THAT ARE ARE RETURNING
TO THESE EMERGENCY ROOMS THREE
FOUR FIVE TIMES A WEEK AND THIS
IS EXTREMELY COSTLY I AND- WE
ARE NOT ABLE TO REALLY SOLVE
THIS UNLESS WE START WITH THAT
ST TO HOME MODEL THAT YOU
MENTIONED SO REALLY APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND-
AS. YOU KNOW WE'RE ALWAYS IN
COMMUNICATION. THANK YOU MR
POLLY ON. YEAH NEXT TO SOMEBODY
WHO HAS MOVED FROM ORANGE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH A SPENDING
MANY MANY IF NOT ALL OF HIS
PROFESSIONAL YEARS WORKING FOR
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE TO NOW
BEING THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF CAL OPTIMA MISTER
RICK RICHARD SANCHEZ HE HAS A
WEALTH OF EXPERIENCE AND A
WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE. AND NOW HE
IS WORKING FOR ONE OF THE MOST
ROBOT BUST HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN ORANGE COUNTY AND-
WE WELCOME MR RICHARD SANCIOUS.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME. THE BRITISH THE
MORNING- AFFARI. OPIC THAT'S
GOING ON HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY
IN UP AND DOWN THE STATE FARM-
I DIDN'T WANT TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT A ROBUST HEALTH PLAN- CAL
OPTIMA CURRENTLY IS THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN. ORANGE COUNTY-
WE'RE A LARGE PROVIDER THAT
AGAIN HOW MANY. EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE THOUSAND NO NO
THAT THAT'S APPOINTED TIME THAT
NUMBER DOES CHANGE BUT THAT'S
PRETTY MUCH- IT'S HARD WE'VE
BEEN IN RECENT I THINK THAT WE
CAN EXPECT THAT THAT NUMBER TO
GROW- IT AND THEN YOU KNOW IF
EVERY WOMAN. HE LOW INCOME
SENIORS ADULTS CHILDREN AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. AND
MANY TIMES WE ALL KNOW YOU'RE
OVERLAPPING POPULATION- BOTH
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE SEEN AT THE
WEALTHY PEOPLE THAT ARE SEEING
THAT- NATION FOUNDATIONS ARE.
LOCATIONS ARE FREQUENTLY
MEMBERS A MEDIC CAL OR AT THE
LOCAL. IF IT ELIGIBLE TO BE
MEMBERS OF CAL. WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT PART AS WELL I DO
HAPPEN LIKE THE SHOW AND I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO SET THAT
UP- BUT IF WE CAN'T TAKE A-
WALK THROUGH IT- YOU COULD JUST
BE A LITTLE BIT LOUDER. BOB.
RICHARD COULD YOU SPEAK A
LITTLE YEAH IT CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW I'M YEAH THAT'S A LITTLE
BETTER. OKAY SO. ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DID EARLY ON WAS WE
NEEDED A PHONE CALL MISSION SO
WE DEDICATED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BUT IT COULD BE
PART OF THE HOMELESS POPULATION.
AND THAT WAS LAUNCHED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND HOPEFULLY EVERY
WOMAN WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT NOW.
YES HELLO YES WE CAN SEE THAT
THE TWELVE MAKE SURE WE GET YOU
TO PLAY YES- OKAY- WE WORK WITH
OUR- COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
TO HELP US WITH THIS
INITIATIVE. TO AN EARLIER POINT
THAT WITH PRODUCT I. DR CHAO
MEETING HOMES WHERE THEY ARE
REFORM CLINICAL FIELD. THEY GO
OUT TO PROVIDE PRIMARY CARE
SERVICES AT SHELTERED POP
ENCAMPMENTS AND OTHER THINGS A
VERY BASIC LEVEL. BOB WAS IS TO
NORMALIZE ALL CARE OR HOME TO
THE VIGIL I THINK MANY PEOPLE
HAVE MENTIONED FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS- YOU KNOW THAT THE-
CONDITION AND. RIDES THE
RESPONSE. AND YOU KNOW AND I OF
THAT IS- NORM. THAT INTERACTION
YOUR HEALTH IS A IMPORTANT AS
THE FINDING THE PLACE TO BE.
FINDINGS OF THE T. FOR ALL THE
INDIVIDUAL OKAY THE PRIMARY
CONCERN. WE'RE TRYING TO
NORMALIZE FAT YOUR HEALTH
ALTHOUGH MY- BUT WE DO WE CAN'T
DO A LOT GOING TO THE SERVER WE
FOR THEIR IN HE'LL WOUND CARE-
MEDICATION AND- WE ABOUT
MALCOLM. AND I WILL PAY THAT
GOES UNDER THE OFFICE EARLIER
COMMENT ABOUT A MONTH OF OUR
FRACTURED- FORTUNATELY AFTER
JALEN I'VE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR
MANY YEARS SO WE'RE WE'RE
BRIDGING THAT GAP. BURKE JUST
FOR EVERYBODY'S EDUCATION. MILD
TO MODERATE MEDICAL POPULATION
AND A BLACK CAL OPTIMA. ADULT
ILLNESSES CANDLE BY COUNTY AND
THAT'S THE WAY IT IS RIGHT NOW
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT WE'RE
WORKING. WE ALSO AND AS
MENTIONED EARLIER ALSO WE ARE
DEALING WITH LOTS OF. WHY THAT
LAST POINT WOULD AMERICANS PRAY
THAT WE DO GET ABOUT UNDER. WE
ALSO READ RATED HOMES RESPONSE
IT TURKEY. AND THESE PEOPLE
WORK WITH A VISA CAL OFTEN LOOK
BOY TAT IS DEDICATED PHONE
LINE AT WORK IN RESPONSE NOT
TWO YEARS EARLIER QUESTION
DOCTOR CHILD BUT GIVEN THE
NUMBER TO THE PUBLIC. IT'S MORE
OF AN INTERNAL SO THE NUMBER
THAT I WOULD USE THE SAME ONE
THAT- DOCTOR CHILD GIVE IT BE
CLOSELY THE NUMBER TO THE
PUBLIC. BECAUSE MONTH THAT
ENTERED THE PUBLIC SYSTEM THAT
GETS YOU ARE A TURKEY AND YOUR
EARLIER POINT ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GET LOCKED IN A JUMBLE OF
NUMBERS IT'S GOOD TO HAVE ONE
POINT NUMBER EVERYBODY
REMEMBERS EIGHT FIVE FIVE WILL
YOU PLEASE AT THE NUMBER TO
CALL YOU WHAT SERVICES FIFA
BEEN GOING. ON WITH THE WHOLE.
BUT THAT ALMOST. HE IS. A
NUMBER CALL AT MANY YOU. BY
WHAT'S CALLED THE GROUP. AND
IT'S BEEN YOUR I FEEL LIKE I'M
REPEATING A LOT BUT- COUNTY-
PEOPLE WORKING ON THE STREET
EVERY DAY I KNOW THAT THAT I
WITH HIM FOR MANY YEARS. YOU
DIDN'T DID YOU WE RELATIONS.
WITH THE HOMELESS PEOPLE. AND
IF THEY SEE SOMETHING THAT IS
IN NEED OF MEDICAL. THEY CAN
CALL UP AND WILL COME OUT YOU
CANNOT MORE THAN FIFTY THAT
APARTMENT- FOR CARE SIR. SO IT
BECAUSE OF ALL THAT I DIDN'T
WANT TO SHOW MUCH LIKE WITH ALL
OF THAT AND- IT WAS ACTUAL DATA
COLLECTED IN OKAY CREATED. ON
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER WE- YEAH
YEAH TURKEY. AND I WILL GRANT
YOU THAT THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE WITH
ROASTED MALT ABOUT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED BUT STILL THIS IS GOOD
DATA SHOW THAT YOU THINK THE
INTERVENTION WORK. REDUCE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS BY
THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT. HE REDUCE
INPATIENT HOSPITAL VISITS- AND
INCREASED PRIMARY CARE VISITS
WHICH IS REALLY A GOOD- NUMBER
THERE BY A 100% SO. MANY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL BECAME MORE
NORMALIZED OKAY I'M GONNA GO HE
MIGHT NOT. THAT IS A GOOD THING
THAT'S SOMETHING I SHOULD BE
DOING. THAT SO WE IN THE PUBLIC
OUT OF. ALL MENTION CAROLINE
AND I CAN'T TALK ABOUT-
ANYTHING REGARDING HOMELESS
WITHOUT FOR YOU KNOW. AND
THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR CREATED CALAIS.
MASSIVE EFFORT. WE FIND IT OR
PUMP OR DOLLARS. HOW MANY OVER
A FIVE YEAR TERM. YOUR
REPORTING WHAT I LIKED ALL THE
TERM MINUTES INTO THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT HEALTHCARE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN YOU MENTION- HOW
IT HEALTHCARE. AND I FREQUENTLY
I SAY HOUSING IS HEALTHCARE-
THIS HEALTHCARE TRANSPORTATION
IS HEALTHCARE ALL OF THESE
UPSTREAM- WITH THAT WE TALK
ABOUT THAT THEN. AT FIRST HELP
OKAY LATER OUR WHOLE. AND I
THINK YEAH HE IS GETTING THAT.
HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY. OKAY
THE- BUT HE KNOWS IN DIFFICULT
CAL HE IS EFFORT. HELP A LEVEL
UNDER YEAH AND FROM MEDICAID
AND MEDICARE. SOCIAL TERM OFHEALTH REALLY THIS THING IT'S
CLOSE BEING FACTORS GO UPSTREAM
INTERVENTION THAT ARE PREVENTED
THE NATURE THAT ACTUALLY
SOMEBODY MENTION OUR COFFEE.
AND SO WE CAN SHOW RIGHT RIGHT
NIKI NEED HAVING THESE
INTERVENTIONS IT HELP WITHIN
THE LAW. WHAT IS THE MOST
EXPENSIVE INPATIENT HOSPITAL
THE MOST. I THINK IT MATH
MENTIONED AS WELL. RESTORATION
IS VERY EXPENSIVE AND TALKING
ABOUT OVERLAPPING POPULATION.
THE EVER MEMBERS ARE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED. FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. I'M GONNA NOT ABOUT
HELLO THIS IS. INTEGRATED BUT
WE LOOK AT ALL THOSE POPULATION
IN THIS NEED THE EIGHT HAVE-
THAT WILL. HAVE THAT
INTERVENTION LEVEL PREVENT
ADVERSE HEALTH. I DO WANT TO
TOUCH UPON ONE THING THAT TELL
UP WILL DO IT AGAIN THROUGH
FUNDING EIGHT- IF YOU'RE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE TERM EASE. AT
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
AND THE MONEY GAVE. THEY DID
CAL OPTIMUM MONEY. DO TENSION
IF YOU VALUATIONS THAT. EIGHT
EIGHT THEN THE WITH OR IF BOTH
MATTER MATH. CONCOCT PERSON
HAVE AT FIRST HOME I'M A
COMPLAINER I. THE BOOK OKAY
NEED BURKE HAVING HEARD OF
BURKE. DOCTOR THAT WORKS THE
GOVERNOR IS NOT SHE LOOKED AT
BUT AND I URGE ANYBODY WHO
FAMILIAR WITH THAT. ACTUALLY A
BLOW OFF TOPIC BUT I DID WANT
TO BRING THAT UP. GETTING BACK
TO- THE FIRST PROJECT WITH THE-
IN A BE IMPLEMENTED ALL EARLIER
HOW ALL HAPPY WITH WHAT SEEN.
KIDS TO. ANCHORMAN THOSE AT THE
CLINIC AND NONCLINICAL NEW A
HIGH COP HIGH PROFIT HIGH
STREET THIS. AND I'LL IN LIEU
OF. IN LIEU OF SERVICES
BASICALLY. YOU DO OTHER SERVER.
AND I PLAYED IT IN BOB VISITS.
UPS FOR. THAT SAVE MONEY AND
ALLOW YOU DO THAT AND THAT'S
THE FOR SOURCE FOR LOOSER- ARE
FIRST MOVES ARE. YOU'RE NOT
HELP THAT HELLO HOW OFTEN WAS
IT OFF INSURANCE COMPANY BE.
YOU WOULD THINK WOULD DO IT
THANK THINGS LIKE. THAT A HAWK
OCTOBER VISITS VISITS- YOU CAN
A BROKEN ARM THOSE ARE THE KIND
OF THINGS WE. THAT THIS IS THAT
FOR OPENING UPS. EVEN LOOK AT
THEIR HOUSE TRENDS APPLICATION
SERVER OKAY OKAY SENATE SEAT
THE INTERPRETER. AND WE'RE FOR
THE CARE ALL OF YOUR HAPPY
ABOUT THAT HERE IS ON THE- SO
EITHER JUST THE FIRST. RT
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY FOUR. ONE
OF MORE ABOUT KELLY EVEN WITH.
A CURFEW. HOW OFTEN THAT WORK
ACT. HE BECAUSE THERE'S ANOTHER
STEP UP AND BE ARMY JUNE
TWENTY. AND THOUGH ARE EVEN
MORE KIND OF UPSTREAM RELATED
HOME WE ARE NAMED ONE OF. THEY
BILL PROGRAM WHAT IS THAT. S.
ONE OUT ONE OF THE SPEAKERS MAY
ON PURPOSE INTO HOW FIRST YOU
KNOW IT IN THE FIRST OFFICE
BRING THEM IN THE HOPES ROOM IS
NOT ALWAYS THAT. IT THAT FIRST
NEEDS THOSE RAPPER SIR. AND
MAKE SURE THERE'S THAT WE CAN.
YES HI. VERY WRAPAROUND. BACK
TO TOP ABOUT THIS AND WHAT THEY
IT TAKES SERVICE DID. YOU YOU
WORK WITH THAT ENDED- OKAY I
RECALL THE FLOOR I SLEEP ON. I
AM MY FRIEND FUNCTION DINNER
EVERY. I GO TO BROKE OR TO FIND
MY. IT THE ARE THE KIND OF
THING FALLING FROM SPACE WHERE
PRIMARY. OUR BY NEWSPAPER WE
AND FINDING TO EAT- FROM.
DIFFERENT SET OF THINGS THAT
NEED TO CONSIDER ONCE YOU'RE
OUT. AND I- I WILL SAY- AND
VERY ENCOURAGED THE- DIRECT IN
THAT FOCUSED CAN IT'S GOING IN
AND CMA TURNED THE L. A. N. AND
FROM THE HEALTH. EIGHT TO MARK.
ALL OF THE THAT THE THAT ARE
COMMON WELL. WE HAVE SOME WORK
TO DO. AND TO. THAT CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN AGREE SPACE FLIGHT.
AT NEEDS TO BE MORE OF A LOT
RECOGNITION THAT. POPULATE I
MENTIONED EARLIER WHERE DO YOU
WITH. FREQUENTLY HAVE TOUCH
POINTS WITH LONG FORCE. THE
NEED TO BE PART. ALL YOU NEED
TO TALK ABOUT. WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT OUR ELDERLY POPULATION
YOU HAVE TO RAISE TWO NOMINEES
COMING UP AT THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS PEOPLE. ARE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AGE. AND I KNOW IT SEEMS
BIG. AND I'M I PUT IN A LOT OUT
THERE BUT YOU HAVE TO START
THINKING BIG. BOB THIS PROBLEM.
SO- EVERY WOMAN I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF ALL OF
THIS. I APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
EFFORTS. NO THE CALLOUT MISTAKE
RIGHT OFF OUT AT. THANK YOU
MISTER RICHARD SANCHEZ CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OFFICER OF
CAL OPTIMA WHICH SERVES AS HE
STATED EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS. AND
ARE WILLING TO SERVE MORE-
AGAIN IF YOU TAKE AWAYS FROM
YOUR COMMENTS AND I APPRECIATE
THEM I REALLY BELIEVE YOUR
BACKGROUND FROM THE COUNTY
GOING TO CAL OPTIMA PUTS ORANGE
COUNTY IN A VERY. EXCELLENT
PLACE TO TAKE YOUR EXPERTISE
FROM THE COUNTY TO CAL OPTIMA.
BUT SOME OF THE BUT TAKE AWAYS
ARE WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT
THERE ARE POPULATIONS WHEN
PEOPLE USE THE WORD VULNERABLE
SOMETIMES IT'S GETS PEOPLE.
NERVOUS BECAUSE THEY THINK OKAY
WE'RE JUST GOING TO BE TAKING
CARE OF ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY
BUT THE TRUTH IS- IT'S-
INDIVIDUALS EXITING THE FOSTER
SYSTEM WE KNOW THEY'RE VERY
PRONE TO FALL INTO HOMELESSNESS
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. IF
THEY'RE NOT HEADED TO COLLEGE
AND WE KNOW MANY OF THEM AREN'T
WE KNOW THAT AS OUR POPULATION
AGES AND THERE ISN'T A SAFETY
NET. AS WAS NOTED MANY WOMEN
SENIOR WOMEN IN THEIR FIFTIES
SIXTIES SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
AND NINETIES. ARE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS WE ALSO KNOW THAT
FORMALLY INCARCERATED. WHETHER
THEY'RE RELEASED. IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND THIS IS THE BIG
MESS THAT ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
THAT ARE HOMELESS ARE COMING
FROM LOS ANGELES OR OTHER NO
ORANGE COUNTY HAS THEIR OWN
HOMELESS AND WE EACH HAVE
HOMELESS THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
OUR OWN. CITIES AND INTEL WE
ADDRESS THIS MYTH THAT THESE
ARE NOT OUR RESPONSIBILITY
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WATCH THIS POPULATION GROW- BUT
AGAIN RIEN. THAT WE GOT TO GET
OUT TO WHERE THE PATIENTS OR
THE INDIVIDUALS. NEED TO THE
SERVICE AND THAT IS NOT ALWAYS
WITH SOMEBODY WALKING INTO OUR
BUILDINGS IT'S AT THE PARKS
IT'S ON THE RIVER BEDS IT'S AT
THE RAILROAD TRACKS IT'S- IN
RETAIL SPACES THAT'S WHERE WE
SEE THEM THAT'S WHERE THEY
NEED. THE SERVICE AND THE HELP
AND THE CONNECTION- THANK YOU
AGAIN. FOR OUR LAST SPEAKER ON
OUR SECOND PANEL MISTER RICHARD
SANCHEZ SO WE ARE GOING TO HEAD
INTO OUR LAST PANEL A AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PRESENTERS BEFORE THE SIX.
EXCELLENT EXPERTS AND- THAT A
MOVE FORWARD TO OUR LAST PANEL
WHERE WE ARE GOING TO DISCUSS
HOUSING AND IMPORTANT OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE AND
COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES WILL
MAKE SOME GENERAL NOTES-
SOMEWHERE ON THE POINT OF TIME
COUNT AND AGAIN I MAY BE VERY
WRONG ON THIS BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT ORANGE COUNTY AT ANY
EVENING HAS BETWEEN SEVEN
THOUSAND AND TEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WE
KNOW THAT ARE THAT ARE NUMBER
REPRESENTS PEOPLE ON OUR
STREETS BUT IT DOES NOT
REPRESENT TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
POSSIBLY LEVINE- WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE VERY CLOSE TO
EVICTION AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE- PEOPLE THAT
ARE LIVING IN THEIR CARS ARE
ARE VIS. WHICH HAS PRESENTED
ITSELF TO BE YET I KNOW ANOTHER
SCENARIO UNDER HOUSING THAT WE
ARE GRAPPLING WITH AN ORANGE
COUNTY. SO WITH THAT WE WILL
PRESENT OUR THREE SPEAKERS- I
WANT TO- MAKE NOTE HERE- THIS
IS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
STAUNTON THE HONORABLE DAVID
SHAWVER WHO I'VE WORKED WITH
NOW ALMOST TO GET DECADE SINCE
MY CITY COUNCIL DAYS. WHERE WE
SERVED ON THE SANITATION BOARD
TOGETHER AND. THIS MAYOR THIS
INDIVIDUAL WAS THE ONLY. MAYOR
AND CITY AND ORANGE COUNTY TO
APPLY FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY
HOME KEY FUNDS WHICH BY THE WAY
THEY APPLIED FOR TO- HOME KEY
PROJECTS AND RECEIVED TWO. I
REALLY APPLAUD HIS LEADERSHIP
WE HAVE THIRTY SIX CITIES IN
ORANGE COUNTY THIRTY SIX WE GOT
TWO AWARDS TWO OUT OF TWO. AND
EVEN IF WE HAD 50% OF OUR
CITIES- THAT APPLIED FOR EVEN
ONE SMALL HOTEL THAT MAY BE HAD
BETWEEN TWENTY TO THIRTY UNITS
PLEASE DO THE MATH HOW MANY
UNITS OF PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WOULD WE HAVE. IF WE
HAD SAY FIFTEEN CITIES THAT
APPLIED AND WERE REWARDED FOR
EVEN TWENTY TO THIRTY UNITS
THAT'S THE WAY WE START TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IT BY EACH
CITY LOOKING AT ONE SPOT WHERE
THEY CAN DO SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAVEN'T ALREADY. DONE YES THERE
WILL BE NEIGHBORS WHO DON'T
WANT IT YES YOU WILL HAVE
COUNCILS WHERE PEOPLE WILL COME
AND SAY NOT IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD.
BUT WHEN YOU DO SOMETHING HIS
BOLD WHEN YOU DO SOMETHING TO
HELP PEOPLE YOU START TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION SO WELCOME
TO OUR HONORABLE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF STAUNTON DAVID SHAWVER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYWOMAN SHARON
QUIRK SILVA I ADMIRE A LOT OKAY
WITH PAUL YES I SEE YOU YOU'RE
LOOKING GOOD YOU'RE MAYOR. OKAY
YOU'RE GETTING A LITTLE OLDER.
ANYWAY GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE. ON ORANGE COUNTY
HOMELESSNESS AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. I'M HONORED TO BE
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING MY
COMMUNITY OUR CITY COUNCIL AND
STAFF. AND I'LL BE SPEAKING
ABOUT PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE AND
COMPREHENSIVE HOUSING PROGRAMS
THAT ARE VERY SUCCESSFUL IT'S
DAY AFTER. ARE NOW BEING
SUPPORTED BY A VARIETY OF STATE
HOUSING PROGRAMS IN COOPERATION
WITH THE COUNTY OF ORANGE. THIS
UNIQUE SYMBIOSIS THERE'S A
REASON FOR OUR SUCCESS. IT ALL
STARTED TWELVE YEARS AGO WHEN
POLYGONUM GIG TO BE LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT OF HIS VISION TO
PROVIDE SHELTER AND SERVICES
FOR HOMELESS POPULATIONS.
ALWAYS FRUSTRATED YOU HAVE BEEN
TURNED DOWN BY EVERY CITY IN
ORANGE COUNTY THAT IT REACHED
OUT TO HIM. I IMMEDIATELY
WALKED PENSION STATEN AND THE
REST IS A HISTORY OF THE
ILLUMINATION FOUNDATION AND THE
IMPACT IT IS MADE EVERYWHERE.
STANTON HAS CONTINUED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A REGIONAL
HEADQUARTERS READ THE
ELIMINATION FOUNDATION AID THE
HOMELESS POPULATION OF ORANGE
COUNTY PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
NEEDED SERVICES AND SHELTER.
HEGEMONY GONE WITH THE
FOUNDATION DR ROBERT HOUSE WAS%
THE FIRST HOUSING PROJECT
INSTANTON. WHERE WE WERE ABLE
TO GET MOTEL KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES OFF THE STREETS. AND
THAT TO A LARGE ALL OFFER
MULTIPLE FAMILIES WITH SCHOOL
AGED KIDS. IT WAS BILL WITH
CHERNOBYL GROUPS ASSISTED BY
OUR STATE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. IT WAS UP AND
RUNNING IN TIME TO GET THE
KIDS. OUT SO THEY DIDN'T MISS
ANY SCHOOL. TO QUALIFY FOR THIS
EMERGENCY HOUSING HAPPEN
THROUGHOUT A FAMILY WAS NOT
ONLY HOMELESS BUT ALSO HAD TO
HAVE A CHILD IN THEIR CUSTODY
ARE PREGNANT MOM AT THE POINT
OF RETURN. NEXT DETERMINED TO
HELP THE COUNTY OF ORANGE THE
COMMUNITY OF STANTON AND ARE
CITY COUNCIL VOLUNTEERED TO
PARTICIPATE. IN OUR CITY. OUR
I'M SORRY TO PARTICIPATE IN
PROJECT ROOKIE WHICH CONVERTED
STANTON AND ENJOY A HOMELESS
FACILITY THAT PROTECTED ELDERLY
AND DISABLED HOMELESS THERE
WERE VERBAL TO THE CORONA VIRUS.
MONDAY FOR PROJECT GROUP HE WAS
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE AND THE
CITY OF STAUNTON. A JOINT
EFFORT BY THE ELIMINATION
FOUNDATION AND CITY. MADE IT A
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE FOR BOTH.
GROUP T. RESIDENTS AND THE
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES OF OUR
COMMUNITY. WE'RE BEING FORWARD
THE CITY'S THERE COULD TRIP TO
COST AND ACQUISITION F.
PROGRAMS TOGETHER WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE AS WITH
IMPORTANT TO CONVERT NOT ONLY
THE STATE MINIMUM IS PART OF
THE NEW HOME KING SUPPORTED.
HOUSING STATE WATER PROJECT WE
INCLUDED THE G. HEATING LOCALE
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
HOUSING UNITS NEEDED IN ORANGE
COUNTY. I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THIS MOMENT TO PERSONALLY THANK
THE AMERICAN FAMILY HOUSING AND
JAMBOREE HOUSING FOR MAKING OUR
WHOLE G. PROJECT AMONG THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL SUPPORTING. HOUSING
IN ORANGE COUNTY. DID WE'RE
WE'RE JUST YOU HERE FUNDING TO
COME OUR THIRD SO HOUSING PRICE
AT THE RIVIERA. WE HAVE MOST OF
THE NEEDED FUNDS ARE SEEKING TO
FINISH THE PROJECT. HE ALSO
OWNS THE PARCEL BETWEEN THE DVD
EVERY. IT WILL BE DONATED TO
BUILD A FACILITY THAT WOULD
PROVIDE SERVICE FOR THESE FOR
BOTH OF THESE SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PROJECTS THE CENTER
WILL PROVIDE RECUMBENT CARE JOB
TRAINING TO GET INDIVIDUALS
BACK INTO A HEALTHY PRODUCTIVE
LIFE. STANTON ALSO AT THIS PARK
HAS THE MOST LOW. LOW AND
MODERATE HOUSING PER CAPITAL IN
CITY IN ORANGE COUNTY HOWEVER
OUR NEXT MAJOR PROJECT IS TO
BUILD ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN THE AREA
THAT IS WHY I AM TRYING TO READ
FOR THE PAST FIFTY YEARS. THIS
PROJECT WILL BE ADJACENT TO ONE
HUNDRED AT MARKET RATE UNITS
THAT WILL SHARE IDENTITIES.
WITH RESIDENTS OF ALL TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE UNITS
INCLUDING SECURITY FENCING
AROUND THE ENTIRE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. ALL TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE UNITS WHAT'S YOUR
COMMON RECREATIONAL FACILITIES
OPEN SPACE AT START PROGRAMS
SWIMMING POOL. LARGE COMMUNITY
BUILDINGS PER DAY CARE AND
ACTIVITIES. ONE VERY POINT THAT
I WANT TO MAKE IT THIS TIME O
BE A DARK COMMITTEE MANAGER IS
THAT WE NEED HELP WITH
RELOCATION COSTS. TODAY THERE
IS NO SPECIFIC FUNDING
AVAILABLE THAN I WILL WEAR A
ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT. HE'S
RELOCATION COSTS SIMPLY DRAIN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RESOURCES AND
KEEP US FROM EXPANDING OUR
PERMANENT HOUSING IT IS NEEDED
IN OUR COMMUNITY. IF THIS
COMMITTEE COULD RECOMMEND TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO HELP
CITIES WITH RELOCATION COSTS IT
WOULD MAKE IT MORE ATTAINABLE
PRESS TO BUILD THE MUCH NEEDED
PERMITTED HOUSING YEAH ORANGE
COUNTY AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AFTER TO REPORT
THAT I PUT THAT I PUT ON
TODAY'S RECORD I'M SORRY I HAVE
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT ALL
THAT I HAVE PUT ON TODAY'S
RECORD. BEGAN ALMOST TWO YEARS
AGO WHEN WE HAD OVER THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY HOMELESS
TRANSIENTS CAMPED. ARE ONLY
THREE AND A HALF SQUARE MILE
CITY OUR REGULAR TRACKS IN OUR
PARKS RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD.
SIDEWALKS IN COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY. WE ACCEPTED THE- OF
PROVIDE OUR PROGRAM HELP THE
SAID. SO THE CITY DEVELOPED A
STATE OF ART PROGRAM IT HAS
BECOME A MODEL FOR THE ENTIRE
COUNTY ORANGE WORKING WITH
JUDGE CARTER. OUR LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY T. WERE ABLE TO COMPLETE
AND RETURN RELOCATE THE ENTIRE
HOMELESS POPULATION IN THREE
MONTHS. TODAY WERE ABLE TO
DISTINCT SINCE THEY ARE EFFORTS
WITH TRANSIT POPULATION WHEN
THEY'RE PUBLIC SAFETY DIRECTOR
OUTRAGE TEAM WHICH IS JACK
CRIST RECENTLY DIVORCED MEMBERS
TO CONTINUE TO BE A MODEL FOR
THE CITIES. OF ORANGE COUNTY.
THIS MARLBORO GRAHAM. IS HAVING
GIVING US THE ABILITY TO OUR
GAP ON. FOLLOWING THE
GUIDELINES OF THE BOYS DISTANCE.
WE'RE ALSO A PURCHASE IN THE
NORTH'S FAULT WHICH RISEN
CITIES AND WHY A PARKING FOLDER
TO. WE ALSO USE OUR LOCAL MOTEL
VOUCHERS SYSTEM THE SYSTEM WAS
NEED SHELTER ARE. IT THE FUTURE.
WHERE WERE WITH OUR NEW CITY JR
COURT HUNDRED FIFTY THIS. THERE
CAN BE BY THE- AIRPORT GEORGIA
ORANGE COUNTY. I HOPE TO
ESTABLISH IT IS ALL INCLUSIVE
FACILITY. THAT WILL HOUSE BOTH
MEN AND WOMEN AND PROVIDED
MEDICAL MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
REHABILITATION ALL IN ONE PLACE.
FIRST OVER TO THE RIGHT THE
ILLINOIS FOUNDATION INSTEAD
APART. AND THIS CARE SPENCER IT
WILL BE THE FUTURE OF
ADDRESSING ALL THE STATE'S.
THESE TYPES OF FACILITIES WILL
AT LEAST HELP OUR WIND CHILL UP
THE HOMELESS PROBLEMS IT
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND DRUG ADDICTION AND
ALCOHOL. IS THE PROBLEM TRANSIT
ELEMENT THAT IS DESTROYING OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. IT MUST BE
INCARCERATED AND TREATED. IN
ADDITION WE ARE PARTING WITH
OUR NEIGHBORING CITIES JABBAR
MOTEL SIX TO PROVIDE OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS. WILL
BE REQUESTING FUNDING IN. THE
FUTURE WITH THIS ADAPTER.
FINALLY SMALL CITY LIKE MY-
SURROUNDING CITIES ORANGE OR TO
SB NINE IF HAVE A LOT OF EIGHTY
ENGINEER HE YEARS AND HE'S
PAYER RESIDENTIAL. THEY WILL
EVERYONE INCLUDING OVERCROWDING
LACK OF PARKING IMPACT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE ESPECIALLY IN MY
SMALL COMMUNITY. BURKE GAS
WATER AND ELECTRICITY. BY THE
WAY IS PROBABLY NOT ONE THAT
THE PURCHASES THESE PROPERTIES
IS BEING GUIDED BY DEVELOPERS
AND OTHER CONTRACTORS OR
TURNING THEM INTO APARTMENT
LIKE HOUSING WOULD YOU GIVE
WILL IMPACT MY SMALL CITY. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT AS WE
GO THROUGH THAT YOU RE EVALUATE
THE SIZE OF THE CITY RELATED TO
THAT BILL. AT THIS TIME I'M
OPERATE IN THE CITY IN ORANGE
COUNTY IT WOULD LIKE TO HELP
OUR INFORMATION ON. OUR
PROGRAMS TO CONTACT ME OR MY
STAFF AND I WILL MAKE THEM
AVAILABLE TO HELP YOU WITH YOUR
HOUSING AND HOMELESS PROGRAM
THE- THANK YOU FOR HELPING US
GET. OUR LOCAL CITIES AND FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PARTICIPATE
TODAY. IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
ASK ME. I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO
OUR CONTINUED RELATIONSHIP WITH
EVERYONE TO MAKE ORANGE COUNTY
A BETTER PLACE TO LIVE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
MAYOR DAVID SHAWVER- FOR THOSE
EXTENSIVE COMMENTS AND- YOU GOT
EVERYTHING IN THERE SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP
TO LOOK FOR CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE MAKING- DIFFERENCE IN
ORANGE COUNTY NOT ONLY FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE BUT ALSO FOR
ENTRY LEVEL HOUSING. WITH THAT
I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ON YOUR TO
PROJECTS THAT YOU WERE AWARDED
IF YOU'RE STILL THERE. DID WE
LOSE- YEAH HE'S STILL THERE IS.
HOW MANY UNITS WERE EACH ONE OF
THOSE PROJECTS FOR THE TO THE
TWO CONVERSIONS. ARE WE WERE WE
WERE CLOSE TO I THINK IT WAS
SEVENTY FIVE ALMOST EIGHTY ACT
OF THE STATE AND THEY HAVE. AND
THE OTHER ONE WE HAVE FORTY SO
I THINK THE TOTAL WASN'T I
CORRECT ME WRONG FALLING
BECAUSE ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY
IS THAT CORRECT. OKAY SO ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY UNITS.
THAT'S JUST IN THE CITY OF
STANTON AND I DID SAY IF WE
WERE TO GET FIFTEEN. ORANGE
COUNTY CITIES REMEMBER THIRTY
SIX CITIES IN ORANGE COUNTY TO
DO A HOME CLEAN HOME KEY
APPLICATION NOW AGAIN I WILL.
NOTE THAT IS NOT AN EASY
APPLICATION YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
WILLING PROPERTY OWNERS BUT
EVEN IF YOU WERE TO GET FIFTEEN
CITIES TO DO TWENTY UNITS FOR A
VERY SMALL A MOTEL HOTEL
CONVERSION THAT'S THREE HUNDRED
UNITS SCATTERED ACROSS ORANGE
COUNTY. AND I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT IS GOING TO BE THE WAY
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THIS
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IT
ISN'T GOING TO BE ONE CITY
DOING MANY MANY UNITS AND OTHER
CITIES DOING. ZERO THE OTHER
AREA THAT I WILL NOTE FROM YOUR
COMMENTS. BECAUSE OF GEORGE
DAVID CARTER BEING INVOLVED IN
HOMELESSNESS IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND NOW OTHER AREAS LOS ANGELES.
THE CITY HAS BEEN DIVIDED INTO
OR THAT I SHOULD SAY THE COUNTY
AND TO THREE SERVICE PROVIDER
AREA SPOT AREAS NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY WHICH STANTON IT
INCLUDES ALSO INCLUDES I'M NOT
GONNA LIST- BUT TEN CITIES OR
TWELVE. HAVE WORKED TOGETHER TO
PUT- WHETHER IT'S THE HOME KEY
PROJECTS IN STANTON WHETHER
IT'S THE A HOMELESS SHELTER AND
ONE OF PARK WHETHER IT'S
ELIMINATION FOUNDATION
RECUPERATIVE CENTER IN
FULLERTON PLACENTIA WITH
ANOTHER HOMELESS SHELTER AND
VETERANS HOUSING ALL OF THESE
MODELS AND FOR SOME OF THE
SMALLER CITIES WHO AREN'T
HOSTING SITES THEY ARE ACTUALLY
PUTTING IN FUNDS. BUT I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DID NOT SAY THAT
EVERY CITY NEEDS TO BE DOING
SOMETHING GIVING DOLLARS TO US
PAUL AREA IS GREAT BUT THE
CITIES THAT ARE HOSTING THOSE
AREAS. IT IS A DRAIN ON THEIR
SERVICES AS YOU WELL KNOW MAYOR
SHAWVER WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING INTO YOUR CITY
FOR CITY OF FOR SERVICES
WHETHER THE WRAPAROUND
RECUPERATIVE- THIS TAKES UP
QUITE A BIT OF POLICE TIME IT
TAKES QUITE A BIT OF TIME FROM
PARKS AND RECREATION FROM THE
LOCAL CITIES THAT ARE HOSTING
THEM. AND SO THIS WOULD BE MY
PLEA I KNOW IT IS NOT POPULAR
BELIEVE ME I KNOW WHAT IS NOT
POPULAR BUT EVERY CITY NEEDS TO
DO SOMETHING EVERY CITY NEEDS
TO BE HOSTING SOMETHING UP AND
AGAIN IF WE ALL DID SOMETHING
IN IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE
POPULATION SIZE OF THE CITY.
CERTAINLY LA PALMA IS THE POP
SMALLER CITY IN MY DISTRICT
THEY SHOULD NOT BE DOING WHAT
FULLER THàNH DOES WHICH IS THE
LARGEST PART BUT IF EVERYBODY
DOES SOMETHING I THINK THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TACKLE THIS
AND- EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE SOME
BEST PRACTICES AND BEST MODELS
AND THERE'S SOME GREAT
LEADERSHIP IF AN ORANGE COUNTY.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE LOOKING TEN
YEARS FROM NOW SAYING WE DID A
LOT BUT WE'RE STILL IN THE SAME
SITUATION BUT I THINK YOU-
MAYOR DE DAVE SHAWVER YOU HAVE
BEEN A LEADER IN THIS AREA AND
I APPRECIATE. YOUR WORK AND I
KNOW- THE PEOPLE OF YOUR
COMMUNITY DO IT TOO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IN THE ONLY CLOSING NOTE IF YOU
PLEASE. WE COULD USE SOME
ADDITIONAL HELP THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY WELL WITH RELOCATION
THAT IS GOING TO BE KEY TO THE
SUCCESS FOR EVERYBODY SO ANY
KIND OF THE SPECIAL RELOCATION
FUNDING THAT THE STATE COME UP
WITH. THE HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'VE I HEAR YOU
ON THAT AND WE HAVE IT LISTED
AS SOMETHING THAT WE COULD LOOK
TOWARDS- OF WORKING ON THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT
A SPEAKER WE HAVE. IS THAT MAN.
MS ELIZABETH HANDS BURKE SHE IS
THE ORANGE COUNTY REGIONAL
DIRECTOR OF U. M. B. NOW WHAT
IS JIM B. AND WHAT IS THE MD.
FOR SOME OF US AGAIN IN THE
CIRCLES THAT WORK ON HOUSING-
THAT IS FAMILIAR TO US BUT FOR
SOME OF US IT MAY NOT BE NIMBY
MEANS. SOMEBODY WHO MIGHT SAY
NOT IN MY BACKYARD LIKE I LOVE
HOUSING BUT DON'T PUT IT RIGHT
HERE PUT IT OVER THERE. YEAH BE
MEANS YES IN MY BACKYARD YES WE
WANT TO SEE MORE HOUSING- NOW.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO INTO A
BIG ARGUMENT HERE BUT THERE'S
IN BC AND THERE'S NIMBYS AND WE
HAVE ELIZABETH HANDS BURKE
HERE- FROM ORANGE COUNTY
WELCOME- MS HANS BERG. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- IT'S
REALLY AN HONOR TO BE HERE WITH
YOU TODAY AND- I'M VERY
GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT ON
HOUSING YOU REALLY HAVE BEEN A
CHAMPION. FOR THE CAUSE OF
HOUSING- I WANNA I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THAT- I'M- THIS
PRESENTATION IS STUFF THAT YOU
KNOW WHILE ROUTE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KIRK SILVA. SO THIS IS
REALLY FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT I'M HOPING
TO REACH WITH MY MESSAGE- I
WANT TO SAY THAT I STRUGGLED
WITH HOW TO TELL THAT STORY.
AND I ALWAYS SAY YOU KNOW YOU
SHOULD WRITE WHAT YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU CAN TELL WHAT YOU
KNOW S I'M GOING TO SHARE WITH
YOU. A STORY THAT I'M GONNA USE
OF THE CASE STUDY TO ILLUSTRATE
THE CHALLENGES OF GETTING TO
YES ONLINE BUILDING PERMITS FOR
HOUSING- WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
YOU KNOW HOUSING IS HEALTH
CARE. I KNOW THAT ORANGE COUNTY
HEALTH PROVIDERS PARTICULARLY
PROVIDENCE ST JOSEPH HEALTH
CENTER THANK YOU MEDICAL CENTER
I KNOW THAT THEY KNOW THAT. I
KNOW THAT BECAUSE PREVENTION IS
WORKING ON IT SO THERE IS
DEFINITELY WHERE DOES AND THE
HEALTH OUR COMMUNITY. THAT
HOUSING IS HEALTH CARE. BECAUSE
A LOT OF WORK DONE ADVOCATE- I
JUST SHARE SO I. AM NOT TRAINED
IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH OR MENTAL
HEALTH I AM ACTUALLY TRAINED AS
AN URBAN PLANNER. SO MY WORLD
REALLY IS- STICKS AND BRICKS
AND WHAT DOES IT TAKE. TO
PROVIDE THE UNIX RIGHT TO
PROVIDE THE FULL USE. THAT
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS NEED
TO MOVE OUT OF. A TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING OR OUT OF THE SHELTER
OR OFF THE STREET AND GO
DIRECTLY INTO HOUSING FIRST SO.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE I'M- THE
DIRECTOR OF THE- I CO FOUNDED
THE UNIGROUP ORANGE COUNTY
WHICH IS CALLED FOR HOUSING- IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND AS OF
TWENTY TWENTY WE BECAME A
MEMBER OF THE LARGER YOU'D BE
ORGANIZATION YOU BE ACTION. AND
SO THAT IS WHERE THE TITLE
ORANGE COUNTY REGIONAL DIRECTOR
COMES FROM BECAUSE YOU BE
ACTION IS THAT STATEWIDE AND-
EVEN GROWING NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I'M GONNA TAKE YOU ON A
LITTLE JOURNEY OF CRIME SO IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. ARE THE CITY
WAS- I'M SORRY THE COUNTY WAS
JUST REALLY STARTING TO GRAPPLE
WITH. YOU KNOW HAVING HAVING
CLEAR THE RIVER BED WHAT ARE WE
GONNA DO. SO THE ORANGE COUNTY
UNITED WAY UNDERSTOOD
UNDERTAKES THE STUDY THE COST
STUDY WITH UCI. THE FINDINGS
BUT IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE TO
LEAVE PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
THAN IT IS. TO PUT THEM IN
PERMITS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
WHICH THAT LEADS TO BE HER.
EFFORT CALLED UNITED TO END
HOMELESSNESS RIGHT- AND THEN AT
THE SAME TIME THAT THAT IS
HAPPENING. I'M NOT A LOT OF
NONPROFIT IN FULLER TEN THAT
USED TO BE CALLED THAT A FULLER
TEN INTERFAITH EMERGENCY
SERVICES. I WHICH GUIDES
PROVIDE OUR EMERGENCY SHELTER
APPROACH. YOUR FULLER CAN WITH
THE IDEA TO BUILD SOME
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
AT. ALL ON A PIECE OF CITY
OWNED LAND WHICH WAS SIXTEEN
HUNDRED WEST COMMONWEALTH
AVENUE- TO THE CITY ON SITE ARE
FOR SEVERAL YEARS BEFORE. ARE
THEY THOUGHT ABOUT USING A FOR
HOUSING- AND IT IS. IS A BIT OF
AN ODD SHAPE- BUT IT IS. IT IS
A CITY OWNED LAND. THAT- THEY
THOUGHT THEY COULD DO SOME WITH.
SO FORWARD TO TWENTY. THE PLAN
FOR NEXT BOB THIS PER FOR
HOUSING SIXTY IN APARTMENTS
HOUSING CHARGES TAKE SHAPE ON
THE COUNCIL. AND EXCLUSIVE
NEGOTIATING AGREEMENT WITH A
PROVIDER PROPER THE POPE I'M
NOT THEY HAVE THREE COMMUNITY
MEETINGS THEY ARRANGED TOWARDS
OTHER PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. PROJECT DEVELOPMENTS
IN ORANGE COUNTY- BUT THERE IS
THERE'S A LOT OF RESISTANCE TO
IT- AND IN FACT THE NIMBYISM OF
THAT ARE THAT WHOLE YEAR WAS
DOCUMENTED BY JOE WORKABLE
FROM- KPCC SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RADIO NPR STATION AND
YOU CAN WATCH THAT ONLINE IF
YOU IS NOT A IT SOUNDS OF
INTEREST BUT- I THE POINT IS
THAT. THE CITY AND PATHWAYS
REALLY DID- AN EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
OUTREACH PROCESS TO TRY TO
BUILD SUPPORT OUR INFORM AND
EDUCATE PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT THIS
WOULD BE AND THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONFUSION ABOUT YOU KNOW IT WAS
A SHELTER IT WAS A SHELTER WAS
A SHELTER. BUT IT WASN'T A
SHELTER IT WAS AN APARTMENT
BUILDING WITH SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WHO NEEDED
THE SERVICE OF THE STATE HOUSE
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
REALLY WAS AN APARTMENT
BUILDING. NOT UNLIKE MANY OTHER
APARTMENT BUILDINGS. SO THIS.
OF THE OUR PERMITS FOR IN HOUSE
PROPOSED. WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
FROM I WE HAD A LOT OF
SUPPORTERS WE HAD- SO UNITED. I
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT THAT CAME
OUT OF ONE OF THE EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIAN CHURCHES AND IS
FUNDED BY OTHER EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIAN CHURCHES. WE HAD THE
ROMAN CATHOLIC CHURCHES IN THE
FORM OF THE TRI PARISH ARE
HOMELESS COLLABORATIVE WE HAVE
THE UNITARIAN UNIVERSALIST
CONGREGATION OF FULLER TEN WE
HAD AN ORGANIZATION CALLED
LOCAL PICO- WE HAD FULLER CAN
ACT AND WE HAD THE POLLUTION
INTERFAITH MINISTERIAL
ASSOCIATION. WHY DO I SHARE
THIS WITH YOU I SHARE THIS WITH
YOU AND ESPECIALLY I'M I'M
SPEAKING TO THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ORDER STAFF
MEMBERS. I SHARE THIS WITH YOU
BECAUSE FULLER CAN HAVE
ADVOCATES WE HAVE PEOPLE IN OUR
CITY WHO DO SUPPORT. OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
UNFORTUNATELY ARE THE NIMBYISM.
OVERWHELMED THAT YEAR WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO MAKE PROGRESS- THIS
IS A PHOTOGRAPH FROM ONE OF THE
COMMUNITY MEETINGS. AND THIS
QUESTION WHY DO THESE ALMOST
PEOPLE GET TO LIVE FREE. AND
HOUSING AND I HAVE TO WORK HARD
TO PAY FOR MY OWN HOUSING- THAT
PRETTY MUCH SUMMARIZES- THE
RESPONSE THAT THEY GOT AND SO.
ON IN OCTOBER BECAUSE OF MANY
FACTORS BUT ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
WE WERE MOVING TOWARDS
ELECTION. PATHWAYS DECIDED TO
WITHDRAW. OUR PARTY APPLICATION.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN. ARE THE
FOCUS ACTUALLY SHIPS AWAY FROM
HOUSING PERMITS FOR HOUSING AND
ACTUALLY SHIFTED SUBURB. AND
THIS IS REALLY IN RESPONSE TO
EVERYONE KNOWS- JUDGE DAVID O.
CARTER'S RULINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
BASICALLY SENDING CITIES IF YOU
WANT TO ENFORCE YOUR CAMPING
WE'RE NOT ANTI CAMPING
ORDINANCES YOU NEED TO HAVE. A
SHELTER. AND SO THAT'S REALLY
WHERE THAT KIND OF MOMENTUM
CAME FROM TO VIEW OF THE
SHELTER BEDS AND WHEN A PARK
AND IN PLACENTIA. ARE AND TO
REALLY AND WE DID STEP UP
FULLER CAN STEP UP AND SO DID
THE OTHER CITIES IN THE NORTH
FONG- AND WE ACCOMPLISHED YOU
KNOW. DOING SOMETHING THAT THAT
UP TO THEN HAD PROVED YOU KNOW
VERY DIFFICULT- BUT IT REALLY
WAS YOU KNOW IN RESPONSE TO THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE LIVING
ON THE STREET AND THE JUDGES
TELLING US THAT WE COULDN'T.
PUT PROVIDE THEM A PLACE TO BE
OTHER THAN THE STREET THEY WERE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO OUT
WE COULDN'T ENFORCE SO IT WAS
THAT PRESSURE THAT REALLY CAME
TO BEAR- THAT WAS WHAT PUSHED
THE CITIES. TO TAKE ACTION-
BEFORE TEN. I AM NOT. WAS ABLE
PUT TOGETHER THE NAVIGATION
CENTER. HELLO MNUCHIN. IS
RUNNING WITH YOU HEARD FROM THE
START- AND WE SAW THE SAME AB.
INFO COME OUT TO SUPPORT THAT
SHELTER THE SAME PEOPLE THAT
HAD COME. SUPPORT THE SIXTY
UNITS OF PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING ON THAT LOT. THOSE SAME
PEOPLE CAME OUT TO SUPPORT A
SHELTER IN A DIFFERENT LOCATION
WAS NOT THE SAME LOCATION THAT.
THAT IS STILL THERE- BUT JUST
TO SHOW YOU THAT WE DO HAVE
ROBUST ADVOCATES IN FULLERTON.
NOW WE'RE IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
CITY IS STARTING AS ALL CITIES
ARE TO LOOK AT SITES FOR
HOUSING ELEMENT WHERE ARE WE
GOING TO PLAY YOU KNOW DO YOU
FELT EVERYBODY GOT REALLY LOT
HIGH REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT NUMBERS ARENA- AND
SO THE CITY IS LOOKING AROUND
AND WERE YOU KNOW THINKING TO
OURSELVES WHERE. YOU KNOW WHERE
COULD WE FIND TO ACCOMMODATE
NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENT- I WANT
TO PUT A PAUSE FOR ONE SECOND
AND JUST SHARE THAT- I DID
FOUND THE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION- BUT I ALSO SIT ON
THE BOARD COMPLAINING
COMMISSION I AM IN MY THIRD
YEAR ON THE COMMISSION I AM
CURRENTLY THAT SHARE THIS YEAR.
AND PRIOR TO JOINING THE
COMMISSION IN TWENTY NINETEEN I
SERVED ON THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT
COMMISSION FOR THE CITY OF
FULLERTON FOR SIX YEARS AND I.
SERVED ON THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION FOR TWO YEARS SO I
HAVE TEN YEARS OF. BEING PART
OF THE PUBLIC PROCESS IN THIS
TOWN AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY I
LOVE THIS TOWN I SERVE THE CITY
BECAUSE I LOVE THE CITY SO IN
SHARING THE STORY WITH YOU IT'S
NOT- I'M I'M SHARING. A STORY
THAT'S HARD TO TELL BUT I KNOW
THIS STORY BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN IT AND IT IT I
THINK THAT MY EXPERIENCE
REALLY- WILL HELP TO ILLUSTRATE
FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COULD NOT I KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW THE STORY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- I THINK THAT. YOU KNOW
THIS STORY IS ILLUSTRATIVE OF
WHAT IS HAPPENING ACROSS ORANGE
COUNTY- SO ANYWAY GOING BACK
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY THE CITY
LOOKING FOR SITES FOR THE
HOUSING ELEMENT OF THIS SITE
SIXTEEN HUNDRED WAS
COMMONWEALTH THAT TRIANGLE SITE
I CHECKED BEFORE ONCE DECLARED
SURPLUS PROPERTY WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN THAT MEANS THAT ACCORDING
TO THE SURPLUS PROPERTY ACT. ON
IT HAS TO BE USED FOR OTHER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR FOR PARKS
SPACE OR SOME COMBINATION OF
BOTH. I'M THE NOTICE OF
AVAILABILITY WINDOWS SEVEN TWO
IT SHOULD BE WHICH THAT STANDS
FOR BUT THE PART OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT IN JULY
AND THE CITY RELEASES AN RFP
FOR AFFORDABLE HEALTH. AND IN.
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU STOP
HOW I'D WITH THE APPLE. THEY
MADE IT CLEAR TO THAT YOU KNOW.
PERMITS WHAT OF HOUSING BEEN
TRIED ON THE SIDE. DID NOT GO.
AND SO THEY WERE WRECKED.
FAMILY SO JUST. FOR HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME. BUT NOT BUT NOT
HAVING ANY CONNECTION TO ARM.
MENTAL HEALTH OR OR IN THE
SENSE PERFECT- AND THAT'S IN
CONTRAST TO THE FIRST PROJECT
THAT WAS PROPOSED WHICH WAS.
FOR PEOPLE THAT WERE EXITING
HOMELESSNESS ARE EXITING
TRANSITIONAL. TO AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT THAT SITE BY MAY HAVE
LOOKS LIKE UNDER ONE OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT WAS BROUGHT
FORWARD- AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
YOU KNOW IT IS AN ODD SHAPED
LOT BUT IT'S KIND OF SANDWICHED
IN BETWEEN- A MAJOR
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDORS THAT
HAS. A MEDIAN IN THE MIDDLE OF
IT AND THE ROVER TRACKS SO IT
REALLYIS A BIT OF A OF AN
ISOLATED PARCEL BUT BUT IT IS
CONNECTED TO THE REST OF
DOWNTOWN IF YOU. IF YOU WALK
EAST FROM HERE YOU DO GET TO A
COMMUNITY CENTER SO IT IS IT IS
CONNECTED BUT IT IS IN SOME
WAYS ALSO ISOLATED AT THE SAME
TIME- TWENTY TWENTY ONE. OUR
CITY STAFF. RELEASES THAT RE
RELEASE OF THE THERAPY. THEY
GET FOR PROPOSALS AND THE
PROPOSALS ARE ALL FROM THE VERY
WELL KNOWN- HOW ARE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS IN ORANGE COUNTY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RIGHT.
NATIONAL CORE RELATED JAMBOREE
AND BETTER HOUSING. AND ON JULY
SIXTH. THE CITY COUNCIL
IDENTIFIED NATIONAL COURT AS
THE PREFERRED. AS THE PREFERRED
DEVELOPER. AND IT WAS
UNEVENTFUL MEETING AND ONE OF
THE COUNCILMAN NOTED THAT IT
WAS A RARITY THAT THE NEIGHBORS
HAVE NOT COMPLAINED OR OBJECTED
TO THE PROJECT. OUT WHICH HE
SAID WAS. A REFLECTION OF THE
FACT THAT. ALL OF THE
DEVELOPERS HAD DONE THEIR JOBS
VERY WELL AND THAT WHAT THEY
WERE PROPOSING TO BUILD WOULD
BE ACCEPTABLE IN EVERY CASE
AND- JUST TO GO BACK AND- TELL
YOU WHAT. WE'RE PROPOSING TO
BUILD. OR FIFTY NINE AFFORDABLE
FAMILY APARTMENTS. ARE FOR
PEOPLE. THAT WERE IT WAS A
DEEPER LEVEL OF AFFORDABILITY
IT WAS AT A VERY LOW INCOME AND
LOW INCOME LEVEL- WHICH ARE THE
HARDEST TO BUILD IN THE HEART
OF THE FUN AND SO THE FACT THAT
THIS COULD BE DONE. ON CITY
OWNED LAND WAS REALLY WHAT MAKE
THAT DEEPER. LEVEL OF
AFFORDABILITY POSSIBLE. SO DO I
SAY FULLER CAN APPROVE. YOU
NINE UNIT AFFORDABLE HOUSE
COMES NATIONAL CORE WITH THE
CHOSEN. AND THEN WE GOT TO
TUESDAY AND IT HAPPENED THE
CITY HAD AN EXCLUSIVE NICK WAS
SUPPOSED TO ENACT AN EXCLUSIVE
NEGOTIATING AGREEMENT WITH
NATIONAL COURT TO ENABLE THE
DEVELOPER TO GO DO THE OUTREACH
TO GO DO THE EDUCATION AND- A
FEW PEOPLE SHOWED UP THEY NOW
AND- THE INTERESTING THING WAS
THAT WE HAD SUPPORT FROM ALL OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAD
SUPPORTED. THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROPOSAL THIS TIME ALL OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THAT
THE TRAVERSE COLLABORATIVE THAT
YOU SAW THOSE WERE THE FOLKS
DRESSED IN WHITE. WE HAD A NEW
GROUP WE HAVE THE UNITED WAY
HOUSING CHAMPIONS WHICH WAS I
AM AN OUTGROWTH OF AGAIN THE
UNITED TO END HOMELESSNESS
INITIATIVE THAT WAS STARTED BY
THE UNITED WAY AND AGAIN THAT
WAS IN RESPONSE TO THE STUDY
THAT THEY UNDERTOOK SHOWING
THAT HOUSING IS LESS EXPENSIVE
A WAY TO HELP FOLKS THAN TO
KEEP THEM IN FILTERS OR TO KEEP
THEM HONEST. MISANTHROPE WE GOT
I SPEED UP BUT YEAH A BIT OKAY
ARE THAT THAT MEETING THAT
HAPPENED ON TUESDAY WAS REALLY
CHALLENGING BECAUSE IT WAS THE
SAME PEOPLE THAT HAD OBJECTED
TO THE OTHER ONE ARE THE. OTHER
PROPOSAL. AND IT'S IT WE HAVE
STALLED NOW ON THIS PROJECT SO
WE HAVE FIVE YEARS A DEVELOPER
CAN'T SPEAK FUNDING. UNTIL THEY
HAVE APPROVALS AND SO NOW THE
CLOCK IS RESET ON THE SITE. I'M
HERE BECAUSE I HOUSING ADVOCACY
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT. IN
THIS POPULAR OUR POPULATION IS
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND. FIFTEEN TENTHS OF A
PERCENT OF OUR POPULATION
OBJECTIVE THIS WAS A TWEET FROM
A MAN WHO ATTENDED THE MEETING
AND HE SAID THAT THERE WERE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIGNATURE TWO
HUNDRED NINE SIGNATURES AND SIX
SPEAKERS. AND THOSE WERE ENOUGH
TO DERAIL THE PROJECT AND I'M
HERE TO SAY AND TO SHARE WITH
YOU MY EXPERIENCE OF THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. THAT NIMBYISM IS
FACTIONALISM IT'S NOT DEMOCRACY
AND I'M FIGHTING THIS THIS
QUOTE FROM FOUNDING FATHER
JAMES MADISON BECAUSE I THINK
THAT NIMBYISM WORKS TO THE
DETRIMENT. OF THE PERMANENT
AGGREGATE INTERESTS OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT IT'S A GROUP OF
CITIZENS WHO ARE NOT DOING THE
BEST FOR THE WHOLE COMMUNITY.
AND I'M SHARING THIS WITH YOU
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE HOUSING
ADVOCATES EVERY CITY THIS IS A
LIST OF ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING ALL ACROSS ORANGE
COUNTY WHERE WE DO HAVE HOUSING
ADVOCATES IN EVERY CITY STAM IS
A VERY SPECIAL PLACE I WILL SAY
THAT I'VE- I AM IMPRESSED WITH
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO.
ACCOMPLISH THEIR- SO. MY
EXPERIENCE IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THERE IS SOMETHING WILL
IRREPARABLY BROKEN AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABILITY. AND
PROCESS TO APPROVE HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE. I WANT TO
ASK YOU MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE END OF THE SENATE.
WHAT IS THE ROLE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO ENABLE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON PUBLIC
LAND IF THE CITIES ARE NOT ABLE
TO PASS IT BECAUSE STANDING IS
A VERY UNIQUE PLACE THE REST OF
THE CITIES ARE REALLY FACING
CHALLENGES. ARE AND YOU KNOW
OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE UNDER
A LOT OF PRESSURE AND THEY'RE
NOT. NOT BEING SUCCESSFUL. AND
I WANT TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE WE NEED TO MAKE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY RIGHT ON
PUBLICLY OWNED LAND. WE NEED TO
DO FOR PERMITS FOR HOUSING AND
DEEPLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHAT
WE HAVE DONE FOR EIGHTY USE
WHICH IS TO MAKE IT MINISTERIAL
BE APPROVED- BECAUSE- THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE NOW WE ARE
FAILING TO BUILD IT WE TRIED
TWICE ON THIS ONE PARCEL. AND
WE HAVE FAILED TWICE AND IT IS
THE SAME SMALL MINOR GROUP OF
FOLKS THAT ARE. HERE TO GETTING
THIS DONE AND I'M SHARING THIS
QUOTE. FROM THE DIRECTOR OF THE
ORIGINAL- ORGANIZATION PATHWAYS
HE SAID THERE IS NO WORLD. IN
WHICH IT IS BETTER TO HAVE
PEOPLE LIVING ON OUR STREETS
THERE'S NO MORAL WORLD THERE'S
NO ECONOMIC WORLD THERE'S NO
COMMUNITY HEALTH VERSION OF THE
WORLD. WHERE IT IS BETTER THAT
PEOPLE ARE LIVING ON THE STREET
AS OPPOSED TO HOUSING AND IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US TO DO. SO I
SHARE THIS WITH YOU ARE AS A
PERSON WHO LOVES OF MY CITY.
OUR AND HAPPILY HAS SERVED AND
ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE
DONE A LOT FULLER HAD TEN HAS
DONE A LOT. BUT EVEN THOUGH
WITH ALL THAT WE HAVE DONE AND
OUR NEIGHBORS HAVE DONE IT IS
NOT ENOUGH. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
AND DEEPLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MINISTER REALLY APPROVAL ON
PUBLICLY OWNED. THAT IS MY ASK.
THAT WOULD MAKE MY LIFE AND THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE- THAT SPOKE
BEFORE US A LOT EASIER BECAUSE
IT WOULD ENABLE THEM TO HAVE A
PLACE. TO MOVE. ARE THERE THERE
WERE. THAT THEIR CLIENTS INTO.
THANK YOU MISS ELIZABETH HANS
BERG- WHO- I KNOW YOU WORK
PASSIONATELY ON THIS TOPIC AND
YOU OPPOSED TO. MANY VERY
SERIOUS QUESTIONS TO THOSE
LISTENING NOW I WILL TELL YOU I
DON'T KNOW WHO HAS TUNED IN WHO
OR WHO HAS NOT TUNE DOWN. WE
DID INVITE OUR OF A- FRIENDS
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE DID
INVITE. SOME OF OUR- CITY
MANAGERS ARE LIST FOR HOUSING
ADVOCATES. BUT I'M NOT SURE WHO
IS ON THIS CALL WHAT I WILL
SAY. IS THAT- TO PUSH BACK A
PRODUCT PROJECT. THAT HAS GONE
THROUGH AS YOU SHALL HAVE SHOWN
IN MANY MANY PUBLIC OUTREACH
MANY TYPES OF PROCESSES IS WHAT
IS DELAYING OR TABLING THESE
PROJECTS IT'S NOT JUST IN
FULLERTON IT'S NOT JUST AN
ORANGE COUNTY. IT REALLY IS
CROSS THE STATE SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT HOUSING AND WE TALK ABOUT
PRODUCTION WE ARE BUILDING AT A
RATE THAT IS LESS THAN THE
FORTIES THE NINETEEN FORTIES
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS LESS NOW THAN
THE NINETEEN FORTIES NINETEEN
FIFTIES AND NINETEEN SIXTIES.
SO EVEN FOR MIDDLE CLASS WE'RE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- RIGHT NOW
HOMELESSNESS IN SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
WHAT WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
OUR WORKING CLASS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR MIDDLE CLASS WHO
CANNOT ATTAIN A HOME. IN MANY
TIMES THE PLACES THEY'RE
WORKING WE KNOW THAT THAT WE
HAVE SEEN AN EXODUS OF PEOPLE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA POLITICALLY
PEOPLE SAY BECAUSE OF X. Y. NZ
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS IS
PEOPLE ARE NOT ABLE TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN THE
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE WORKING AND
LONG COMMUTES WHETHER IT'S AN
HOUR HOUR AND A HALF OR SIMPLY
A QUALITY OF LIFE ISSUE. SO YOU
ARE EXACTLY RIGHT MRS AT MS
HANS BERG WHERE WHEN WE SAY NO
WE PUSH OFF THE OF PROJECTS
WHEN WE HAVE COUNCIL MEMBERS
WHO ARE NOT SAYING YES BUT IN
SAID STATE. NO OR DELAYED
PROJECTS IT ADDS TO THAT
PRODUCTION ISSUE. I KNOW THAT-
THERE IS MANY MANY PEOPLE
INVESTED IN TRYING TO BUILD
WHETHER IT'S MARKET RATE OF
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND TO BE
HONEST WE'RE NOT DOING VERY
MUCH OF ANY OF THE HOUSING. AND
SOME OF THE BILLS THAT THERE IS
OPPOSITION TO THOSE AGAIN
PRESENT A NARRATIVE THAT MANY
TIMES. ARE NOT THE FACTS OF THE
BILL. MANY TIMES THE BILLS
HAVEN'T EVEN BEEN READ BEFORE
UP PEOPLE ARE SAYING NO TO THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION SO. WE'VE
GOT A PROBLEM WITH HOMELESSNESS
WE'VE GOT A PROBLEM HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND WE'RE NOT
ADDRESS SEEN IT EITHER SO
WITHIN ONE WE HAVE PEOPLE
COMING IN AND SAYING WELL
CALIFORNIA HASN'T DEALT WITH
HOMELESSNESS. IT'S A CRISIS
IT'S A IT'S A DISASTER. MY
QUESTION IS WHAT IS YOUR
SOLUTION IF YOU DON'T WANT
PEOPLE ON YOUR PARKS IN YOUR
BUSINESSES YOU DON'T WANT
HOUSING BEING BUILT IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOODS YOU DON'T WANT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES WHAT IS YOUR
SOLUTION BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE
ARE FAILING MANY MANY PEOPLE
INCLUDING ARE WORKING FAMILIES
IN. OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE WILL MOVE
TO SOMEBODY WHO IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE PROJECT- RIGHT
NEXT DOOR IN ANAHEIM- MISTER
BENJAMIN HURST WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS FOR THE
SALVATION ARMY OF ORANGE
COUNTY. AND I'M HOPING HE WILL
LEAD US INTO THE INDIA INDIAN
OF THE SESSION ON A LITTLE MORE
UPBEAT NOTE HERE WELCOME. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON I WANT TO THANK- YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA FOR
THE EXTRAORDINARY INVITATION.
TO JOIN THIS PANEL CHAMPIONS
AND CELEBRATE- GREAT INNOVATION
AND PROGRESS IN THE BATTLE.
AGAINST WHAT WE REALLY BELIEVE
IS THE DEFINING HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS OF OUR TIME OF COURSE
I'M SPEAKING TODAY OF.
HOMELESSNESS AND WE CELEBRATE.
SO MANY OF THE GREAT THINGS
WE'VE HEARD TODAY IT IS SO-
HEART WARMING TO HEAR OF OUR
COMMUNITY FRIENDS AND ALLIES.
IN THE SPACE- FIGHTING-
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH US
AGAINST THE RAVAGES OF
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS ORANGE
COUNTY- LET ME BEGIN. BY A NON
BURYING THE LEAD TODAY. LET ME
SAY COMPREHENSIVE BELIEVE THAT
THE SALVATION ARMY DOESN'T
BELIEVE ORANGE COUNTY HAS A
HOMELESS CRISIS WE CANNOT SOLVE.
A WE BELIEVE WE HAVE A HOMELESS
THROUGHPUT PROBLEM THAT
TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY AND AS
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE
COMMUNITY WE CAN UNITE TOGETHER
AND COMPREHENSIVELY AND
COLLECTIVELY SOL. AT THE
SALVATION ARMY BELIEVES THAT
OUR FRIEND OUR NEIGHBOR OUR
LOVED ONE SOMEONE AYE
AFFECTIONATELY CALL
METAPHORICALLY JOE HOMELESS.
CAN EXPERIENCE COMPREHENSIVE
LIFE TRANSFORMATION AND EMERGE.
LIKE A PHOENIX OUT OF THE
BROKEN ASHES OF YESTERDAY AS
JOE SO. COMMUNITY CONTRIBUTOR
THERE WE EVEN SAY TODAY JOSEPH
FUTURE TAX PAYER AND EXPERIENCE
THE PERSONAL DIGNITY OF
VICTORIA'S AUTONOMOUS LIVING
AGAIN I WANT TO TOUCH ON THAT
BECAUSE THE SALVATION ARMY IS
ONE THE LARGEST PRIVATE SHELTER
OPERATORS IN THE UNITED STATES
WE HAVE OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
BEDS NATIONWIDE IN THE LOW
BARRIER SHELTER SPACE WE ARE
ALSO ON THE FRONT LINES OF
HOUSING FIRST DEVELOPMENT OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND I AM SHARING AN IMAGE OF
OUR ICONIC- CAMPUS UNDER WAY IN
ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA THE CENTER
OF HOPE THAT WILL HAVE DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS AS A
HOUSING FIRST RESPONSE TO THE
HOMELESS CRISIS AND- TO BUILD
ON WHAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS SAID
TODAY. YOU NEED A GREAT PARTNER
IN THIS DEBATE AND WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE OF- THE LEADERSHIP
IN THE CITY OF ANAHEIM
PARTICULARLY TO DEPARTMENT HEAD
LEVEL THAT HAS NOT REALLY
LOCKED ARMS AND REMOVED ALL
OBSTACLES TO SEEING ALMOST
HOUSING GO UP AT THE CENTER OF
HOPE SO I WHAT I WANT TO TURN
THIS CONVERSATION IF I COULD IN
A UNIQUE DIRECTION FOR JUST. A
FEW MINUTES WITH MY TIME TODAY.
TUCKED AWAY A QUIET STREET OFF
LOUIS STREET IN ANAHEIM IS THE
SALVATION ARMY ADULT
REHABILITATION CENTER. AND THE
REASON I DRAW ATTENTION TO THAT
TODAY AT THIS TO STEAM PANEL IS
THE SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THE A. R. C. HAS HELPED- MEN
AND WOMEN. THAT COME TO THEM IN
THE DEATH GRIP OF THE SERIOUS
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ADDICTION. AND
TODAY PER RESIDENTS THAT
GRADUATE THAT SIX MONTH
PROGRAM. WE SEE AN ASTONISHING
30% SOBRIETY RETENTION AT THE
ONE YEAR MARK. THAT MAY NOT
SOUND LIKE MUCH BUT COMPARED TO
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF 8% THAT
IS REALLY EXTRAORDINARY. SO I
STOPPED BERMAN. AND I ASKED THE
QUESTION WILL WANNA HOMELESS-
HOUSING PANEL WHAT I LEAD WITH
THE STORY OF RECOVERY- WE DO
THAT BECAUSE THE LIFE STORY
SCENE AND THAT RECOVERY SPACE
ARE ALL TOO OFTEN SIMILAR TO
THE BROKEN LIVES WE DEAL WITH
THAT ARE HOMELESS SHELTER. FOR
TOO MANY OF THOSE THAT IN OUR
A. R. C. RECOVERY PROGRAMS
FAMILIES OF ALL BUT GIVEN UP
FUNCTIONAL HOPE. SOCIETY HAS
ALL BUT TURNED OUR BACK ON THE
PROSPECT THAT THESE- FRIENDS
NEIGHBORS LOVED ONES IN THE
SHELTERS WILL HAVE ANY FUTURE.
AND YET THE LESSONS LEARNED IN
THAT RECOVERY SPACE TELL US
LOUDLY TODAY THAT OUR BATTLE
AGAINST THE PURSE THE RAVAGES
OF HOMELESSNESS. WE AS A
SOCIETY DO NOT HAVE TO GIVE UP.
THAT WE AS A COMMUNITY DO NOT
HAVE TO SURRENDER CAN YOU
IMAGINE WITH ME. AND IN THE
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF TWO WORDS
OF OUR ANAHEIM EMERGENCY
SHELTER THAT I'VE GIVEN THE
CIVIC LEADERS ACROSS THE SOUTH
LAND. I INVITE YOU TO IMAGINE
IF WE COULD SEE. A SUBSTANTIAL
PERCENTAGE OF OUR HOMELESS
FRIENDS JOURNEY THROUGH A
COMPREHENSIVE THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAM THAT LIBERATES THEM
FROM THE CRIPPLING BOND AGES OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THAT
REACTIVATES THEIR ABILITY TO
WORK AND HOLD WELL PAYING JOB
THAT BRINGS HOPE TO THEIR
OUTLOOK ON LIFE. AND
RESTORATION TO THEIR BROKEN
FAMILY SUPPORT STRUCTURES WHAT
IF WE WITNESS EVEN A THIRTIES
30% SUCCESS RATE IN SUCH A
MONUMENTAL ENDEAVOR WE DARE SAY
TOGETHER TODAY WITH ASPIRATION
IN OUR HEARTS IT WOULD CHANGE
THE STORY ARC OF HOMELESSNESS
IN THE UNITED STATES. AND SO IN
THE SPRING OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE HAVE BEEN ON A QUEST AT THE
SALVATION ARMY IN ORANGE COUNTY
TO BRING TOGETHER ALL THE BEST
AND BOLDEST ELEMENTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY HOMELESS INITIATIVES
AND. HOPE CENTER HOPE TODAY IS
HOME TO THE SALVATION ARMY
ADULT REHABILITATION CENTER
WITH ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE BEDS FOR MEN AND WOMEN
EXPERIENCING RECOVERY FROM
SUBSTANCE ABUSE ADDICTION THE
CENTER OF HOPE TODAY IS HOME.
TWO THREE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
BED LOW BARRIER EMERGENCY
SHELTER GIVING IMMEDIATE TRIAGE
OFF THE STREETS. AT THE CENTER
OF HOPE WILL BE HOME. TO DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS AND A
HOUSING FIRST EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS. AS
OUR HOUSING UNITS BREAK GROUND
IN DECEMBER OF THIS YEAR. THE
CENTER OF HOPE. WILL BE HOME TO
THE HOMELESS THROUGHPUT SYSTEM
BEING ROLLED OUT NOW. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY OF
ANAHEIM AND- COUNTY OF ORANGE.
AND COMMUNITY- PARTNERS ACROSS
THE REGION. SO WE TALKED TODAY
IF I COULD DRAW YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE HOMELESS THROUGHPUT
SYSTEM WHERE. THE FIRST BASE
REPRESENTS THE GREAT WORK BEING
DONE AT LOW BARRIER SHELTERS
EVERYWHERE SERVING AS VITAL
ENTRY POINTS ON A CONTINUUM OF
CARE. THAT LEAVES THEM UPON
EXPRESSWAY OF RAPID HOUSING
PLACEMENT. BUT WE ALL KNOW
TOGETHER. WE DON'T WANT OUR
RESIDENTS RESIDING IN SHELTERS
VERY LONG THIS IS TRIAGE SPACE.
THE ARCH CARE WE'RE TOGETHER
WITH- FRIENDS LIKE POLLY ONET
THE ILLUMINATION FOUNDATION
WHERE WE DO TRIAGE CARE AND
LEVERAGE ALL OUR COMMUNITY
RESOURCES TO BRING VICTORY IN
THAT SPACE AND WE MOVE THEM AS
RAPIDLY AS POSSIBLE TO SECOND
BASE. HOUSING FIRST INITIATIVES
IN TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AND
RAPID RE HOUSING BECAUSE WE
KNOW STATISTICALLY THAT
RESIDENTS PLACED QUICKLY INTO
HOUSING. HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARY
SUCCESS RATE AS MANY AS 80%
HAVE A HOUSING RETENTION MARC.
IT THE TO YOUR POINT. SO WE
WANT TO BUILD ON THE SUCCESSES
OF AMERICA'S THIRTY YEAR POLICY
OF HOUSING FIRST AND GET THEM
HOUSE QUICK. BUT HONESTY
DEMANDS TODAY THAT THE
CONVERSATION CANNOT STOP THERE
WE KNOW ALL TOO WELL THAT
HOUSING EFFORTS ALONE. CANNOT
SOLVE THE HOMELESS CRISIS I AM
DEEPLY MOVED BY THE STORY THAT
I TELL THIS IN A NONPARTISAN
WAY OF THE MAYOR OF SAN
FRANCISCO GAVIN NEWSOM IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR HOW HE
CALLED A PRESS CONFERENCE AND
ANNOUNCED. THERE WOULD BE A
RATIFICATION OF WIDESPREAD
HOMELESSNESS IN SAN FRANCISCO
INTENT WITHIN TEN YEARS BECAUSE
THE THEY DEVOTE EXTRAORDINARY
RESOURCES IN THE CITY TO
BUILDING AND HOUSING AND
MOBILIZING AND I'M DEEPLY MOVED
BY THAT STORY BECAUSE OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS THEY DID SPEND
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
ON HOMELESS SERVICES. OVER THE
NEXT TEN YEARS THEY DID
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION OVER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE OFF
THE STREETS AND INTO HOMELESS
HOUSING IT WAS AN EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORT. AND YET WHEN THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHRONICLE FOLLOWED UP
ON THE PRESS CONFERENCE TEN
YEARS LATER. WE HUNG OUR HEAD
IN DISAPPOINTMENT AS THE CITY'S
HOMELESS COUNT WENT UP 3% AFTER
ONE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
SPENT EIGHTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
HOUSE. EDIT IT TOLD US A LESSON
IN OUR NATIONAL ECONOMIST
APPOINTED OUR ATTENTION TODAY.
THAT FOR REASONS WE DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHY- WE HAVE TO
BUILD TEN UNITS OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING TO SEE A NET
ONE INDIVIDUAL DECREASE IN A
COMMUNITY POINT IN TIME COUNT.
AND THESE ARE FISCAL MODELS
THAT NO COMMUNITY CAN SUSTAIN
SO WE GO BACK TO THIS ISSUE. WE
WANT SHELTERED WE WANT HOUSING.
WE'RE BUILDING HOUSING AT THE
CENTRE POPE IN ACROSS THE
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY. BUT WE
WANT TO PUT THE ATTENTION ON
THE DINING. IN THE DIAMOND OF
THE BASE PATH WHICH IS THIRD
BASE. WHICH FOCUSES ON
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY RE
INTEGRATION YOU SEE WE BELIEVE
THAT WITH ADVANCED SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT WITH COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY APPLICATIONS
WITH THERAPEUTIC WORK
REINTEGRATION MODELS WE HAVE
SEEN AFTER THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF
DOING IT SUCCESSFULLY IN THEIR
COVERAGE BASED. WE KNOW WE CAN
SEE LIFE REHABILITATION AND
EVEN COMMUNITY REINTEGRATION
WHETHER ALMOST FRIENDS
NEIGHBORS LOVED ONES AND WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT TO WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THIS SPACE. THE SALVATION
ARMY AND OUR FRIENDS ON THIS
PANEL TODAY WE DON'T SAY THIS
IS AN EXCLUSIONARY WAY WE SAY
THIS IN A COLLABORATIVE WAY.
AND WE HAD NO WAY SHAPE OR FORM
ENDEAVOR TO WAREHOUSE PEOPLE
WITH NO HOPE FUTURE DESTINY OR
PURPOSE. WE WANT TO GET THEM
HOUSING GET THEM HOUSE RAPIDLY.
WHAT'S AROUND THEM WITH THE
BREAKTHROUGH CARE STRATEGY-
THEY CAN INTRODUCE THEM TO A
LIFE OF VICTORIA'S AUTONOMOUS
LIVING AGAIN- WE BELIEVE THAT'S
THE FUTURE OF HOMELESSNESS CARE
IT'S A FUTURE THAT TAKES THE
CONVERSATION BE ON. JUST
HOUSING. AND SAYS LET'S GET
HOLISTIC LIFE TRANSFORMATION
GOING IN THIS SPACE LET'S GET.
EVEN BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE RE
INTEGRATED INTO SOCIETY AND A
VICTORIOUS WAY. AND IN DOING
SO- WE ASPIRE ARE THE BEST
THINGS THAT AMERICA IS ALL
ABOUT. THAT'S REALLY ON MY
HEART TODAY I APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND THE INVITATION TO
SHARE ON THIS EXTRAORDINARY
PANEL AND I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE ALL MY FRIENDS AND
THE EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS.
DOING IN THIS SPACE THANK YOU
AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORK
SILVA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BENJAMIN HURST THE
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS FOR THE
SALVATION ARMY OF ORANGE COUNTY
AND THE NEWEST PROJECT THAT
THEY ARE WORKING ON- THE CENTER
OF HOPE IN ANAHEIM. AND I
REALLY THINK THAT- YOUR- INDIEN
OUR PANEL ON REALLY WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT WHICH IS PEOPLE AND SO
OFTEN WE USE THE WORD
HOMELESSNESS- PEOPLE DON'T.
HAVE THE FACE OR THE STORY I
AND A AND A TO OFTEN IT IS
REDUCED TO THEY OR THEM AND
WHAT YOU KNOW WHY DO WE NEED TO
CARE ABOUT THIS IN YOUR PASSION
BY THE WAY YOU SPEAK. AND THE
SENSE OF RESTORING LIVES IN THE
SENSE OF. THE IDEA THAT NOT
ONLY CAN ANALYZE TO BE RESTORED
BUT WE CAN EVEN GET PEOPLE BACK
TO A NOT ONLY ENGAGING IN
SOCIETY BUT CONTRIBUTING I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
ELEMENT IN THE VERY INSPIRED
BY- YOU ARE FINISHING OFF HERE.
I WILL. AGAIN THANK ALL OF OUR
ROAST BUST. EXPERT PANEL AND
EXACTLY AS STATED MANY OF THESE
PANELISTS KNOW EACH OTHER
BECAUSE THEY'VE WORKED WITH
EACH OTHER WITH AN ORANGE
COUNTY THEY HAVE- A SPENT TIME
AT NUMEROUS COLLABORATIVE'S
NUMEROUS MEETINGS ARE SHARING.
INFORMATION TRYING TO DO WHAT
CAN BE DONE TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION. CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
BOLD ACTION. TO BE. TAKEN STEPS
BACKWARD BY IN ACTION IN THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS- SO THAT
EVERY STEP WE MAKE GOES
BACKWARDS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
DOING THE BUILDING BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT SAYING YES SO WITH
THAT WE DO NOT WANT TO OPEN IT
UP TO PUBLIC COMMENTS AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HEAR
FROM MARK. UP PUBLIC LET ME GO
AHEAD AND- OFFER YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY A CALL IN I BELIEVE
THE PHONE NUMBER IS I SAID THAT
IN THEM THE BEGINNING I'M GOING
TO GO ALL THE WAY BACK TO MAKE
ANY NOTES AND LET YOU KNOW THAT
PHONE NUMBER AGAIN TO CALL IN.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT- YOU WOULD CALL
IN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN IT IS ON
THE SCREEN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN USING THE PIN CODE POUND
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. WE WILL BE KEEPING THE
LINE ON INTEL ONE PM IS THAT
CORRECT. ONE PM FOR TELL LISTEN
TO ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS-
MODERATOR PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
OPEN UP THE LINES. IN LEADING
GERMAN DEPLETE YOURSELF IN
QUEUE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW.
IF YOU ARE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE THIS AFTERNOON IT MAY BE
HELPFUL IF THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THOSE NUMBER KEYS ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF INTO
Q. WE DO NOT HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY TWO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- FOR. NUMBER
IS TIED AGAIN BY EACH MAN ON
BEHALF OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE AN INDEPENDENT PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE DEDICATED TO
ADVANCING FOUND BRAIN HEALTH
POLICY AND INSPIRING LEADERSHIP
ON THE ISSUE WE JUST LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO INVESTIGATING ON
THE DRAFTING INTERSECTING
POLICY CHANGES MEETING THE
NEEDS OF PEOPLE BOTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
WORKING WITH THE SIX YEAR
MENTAL ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WHICH TAKES SKILL AND
COMMITMENT BUT IT CAN BE GONE I
LOOKED AT THE EXAMPLE OF THE
CITY OF BAKERSFIELD. AS OF
JANUARY THAT YEAR THEY
ELIMINATED CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS
SIX YEAR COLLABORATION WITH
PUBLIC PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT
PARTNERS MARAKWET SHOULD BE
REPLICATED. BY OTHER CITIES AND
COUNTIES. ALL OF THE AMPLE
MISTER MONKEY COMMENTS ABOUT
THE HIVE INTEGRATED. SO COUNTY
WELL CAN IN BEING MODEL FOR
MULTIPLE LET AS BEING MORE
CARRIAGE IN ONE LOCATION. WE
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER HOW THE BE
WELL APPROACH CAN BE SCALED UP
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND PROMOTING SOLUTION
FOR THE CHALLENGE BUT PROBABLE
PROBLEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN JUST
A REMINDER IS PRESSING ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF YOU LIKE TO
PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
NOW I HAVE ONE
MORE LINE LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ED
DAVIS I DO LIVE IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND AS AN ADVOCATE WITH
THE ON THE HOUSE SINCE WELL
BEFORE THE RIVER BED AND I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRINGING FOLKS TOGETHER
AND FELT LIKE A MEMORY TOUR OF
SORTS AND FILLED WITH HOPE AS
WELL BUT I DO HAVE SOME
COMMENTS BECAUSE AS AN ADVOCATE
EXCUSE ME AND I. POLICE HAVE
DONE A LOT. FOR THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE BEEN. IN THE TRENCHES
TRYING TO ADVOCATE STRONGLY
IT'S USUALLY. THERE ARE CERTAIN
INTERNET KICKING AND SCREAMING
THAT CITIES HAVE COME FORWARD.
PAT ARE YOU THERE ARE STILL.
THE WAY BM THE CONCERN THAT I
HAVE AT THIS POINT IS THE ISSUE
AROUND. WHAT LAND USAGE AND HOW
CITIES ARE TAKING THAT
SERIOUSLY RIGHT NOW OUR COUNCIL
GOVERNMENT SAYS BILLION EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR THURMOND AND
NUMBERS WHICH- DOESN'T SEEM TO
HELP SHOW ANY COMMITMENT. THE
MOTEL PLACEMENT I THINK- MISTER
SANCHEZ MENTIONED THAT IT
DIDN'T WORK WELL WRAPAROUND
SERVICES WERE ALWAYS A PART
THAT MODELED SO. AGAIN PLACING
A PERSON A MOTEL NOW. IN TERMS
OF MONEY COMING FOR FEDERAL AND
STATE DOLLARS LIKE SOMEONE ELSE
STAFF SO I THINK IT WAS MISS
HANDS BURKE BUT CAN THE STATE
DO TO ENSURE NOT ONLY THAT.
OKAY LAUGHTER THE MONEY WHICH I
KNOW IT'S THEIR CHOICE BUT IF
IT'S USED PROPERLY IT'S HUGE-
AND THE IN HOUSE ARTIFACTS.
MANY ARE MY PART TIME I LOVE
THE THROUGH MOM AS- WITHOUT
BOOKS LINGERING. IN SHOW. FOR
EVER THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN JUST A REMINDER IS
PRESSING ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
TO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE.
NEXT WE HAVE ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
WE'RE HERE. OKAY ARE MANY
PANELS TODAY I SPOKE ABOUT THE
TREMENDOUS PARTNERSHIPS AND
INNOVATIVE METHODS THAT HAVE
BEEN CREATED TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN ORANGE COUNTY
YEAH WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
COSTS OF HOMELESSNESS TO ALBEIT
MOVING TO BUSINESS HERE. AND
THIS SUGGESTS THAT WE HAVE THE
STAKE IN ANY HOME AND COUNTY.
IN ORDER TO BE THOSE COSTS OF
ALMOST THOSE AND TO PRESERVE
OUR QUALITY OF LIFE HERE. WHAT
TO KEEP UP. BUT I THINK THAT
STILL MISSING ARE SOLUTIONS. IT
IS A PARTNERSHIP THAT INCLUDES
OUR- COMMUNITIES AS A WHOLE. TO
PROVIDE HOUSING. OF COURSE WE
NEED LANDLORDS TO PROVIDE
UNITS. WE NEED A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT
FOR PERSONS- THAT ARE SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT. AFTER ALMOST AS-
WIDE AS SPACE. OUR UPGRADE
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR ALMOST FIVE
REPORT. WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW IS. IT'S WHAT THE LORD
JOHN WHAT ARE THE GOING TO. I
IN ORDER TO BRING. THE MEMBERS
OF THE- IT TO THE WAITED. I
CAN'T SEE WHAT A TREE SO ARE
CHAT DEPENDING ON THE ORANGE
COUNTY. YEAH I MISS MY NAME IS
KIM HOW TO. I'M ON THE CARE
BOARD. AND- YEAH THANK YOU GOT
JUDY- TO BE ABLE TO MAKE MY
CALL TODAY IN FACT SHE WAS A
WOMAN FROM SOLAR. FOR- BURGER
RANGING TO START TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. EXTRA WE HAVE
ONE THIRTY YOUR LIFE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GUESS GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY QUIRK SILVA
AND SPECIAL WITH ORANGE COUNTY
UNITED WAY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
OKAY I THOUGHT YOU MOVE FORWARD
WITH ENSURE IF YOU COULD I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR- NICK- EVENT THIS MORNING
WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
THAT GOOD CONVERSATION- AND
SOME POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS ONE
SOLUTION THAT I WANT TO
REITERATE ON AND THEY KNOW
WE'VE DISCUSSED IN THE PAST IS-
OUR ABILITY ORANGE COUNTY
UNITED WAY YOU'RE WELCOME HELLO
THREE. OUR ABILITY TO HELP
PEOPLE QUICKLY AND SCATTERED
SITE HOUSING WITH VOUCHERS THAT
ARE PROVIDED BY HAD BUT WE HAVE
A LANDLORD REIMBURSEMENT OUR
LANDLORD INCENTIVE PROGRAM
WHICH IT INCENTIVIZES LANDLORDS
SHOULD TAKE BOTH BELCHER
HOLDERS WE PROVIDE NAVIGATION
SERVICES FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE TO
GET INTO HOUSING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. WE ALSO FIND A STRONG
NEED FOR SUPPORTIVE SERVICES I
THINK THIS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS BY MANY
DIFFERENT SPEAKERS BUT THOSE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. THAT ARE
PROVIDED BY OUR SERVICE
PROVIDER PARTNERS WHICH FOR A
YEAR OF HOUSING STABILITY IS
ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE WAY THAT
WE CAN KEEP OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION THAT HAS BEEN
RECENTLY HOUSE. STABLY HOUSED
AND CONTINUING TO THE HOUSE.
ONE THING I HOPE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
ADEQUATELY FUNDED THOSE
NAVIGATION AND SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS HOUSING
VOUCHERS. ARE ABLE TO GET HOW
AND HAVE THE SUPPORT OF
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT
UP WE HAVE LINE TO EIGHT YOUR
IS OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. THANK.
ALL. EIGHT YOU FOR SUPPORTING I
THAT. RIGHT ALMOST DONE. SB
NINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD CREDIT CARD WHICH ALL OF
THE CALLS YEAH SO MANY
CURRICULUM WE ARE PLEASE YOU
SPEAK FROM THE VERY NEXT GRASS.
WHEN PARKING ONE OF THE-
SHOOTING CAL STYLES WRONG.
AMONG THE MORE IN THE FIRST
COUNCIL. THANK GOODNESS. BUT WE
HAVE A PROBLEM HOW THE- ARE
SERVICE HUNDRED FOUR TWO PEOPLE
AND YEAR THE LAST MILE. CONTROL.
JAMBOREE HOUSING BILLS INTO LAW.
SUPPORTING PUBLICLY HOUSING
UNITS CONVERTING THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY LOOKING ACCORDING TO
THREE LOW TELLS CHRIS TO HAVE
MORE. TWENTY THOUSAND. HI
CRIMINAL THE PARK WILL. USUALLY
WHEN I HELD PERSONAL WORKS FOR
CAL'S HERE TO CONVENTION.
ACTUAL WHO NEEDS IN THE- STATE
CAL ONLY A LOOK AT. HELLO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR PROVIDING SOCCER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH. WHAT
WHAT IS NOISE. OKAY ALL RIGHT
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT
THEN. NEXT WE HAVE A THIRTY
FIVE YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OUR OBJECTIVE TERRY LONG
AND BARKER- GOOD MORNING GOOD
AFTERNOON- FIRST TIME WHERE
THANK I WAS THE BEST PUNCH
BURKE FOR HIGHLIGHTING- THAT
THE BAKUL IN ORDER TO AND I WAS
THERE TO STAY WITH MY FRIENDS
FROM YOU YOU SEE UP UNTIL.
AFTER MIDNIGHT AND IT WAS VERY
FRUSTRATING AND I'M I'M GLAD
THAT STARTED GETTING UP. BUT I
WAS DISCUSSING WITH THE
COUNCILMAN- GETTING- OUR
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD. OUR OUR LOW COST
HOUSING BY RIGHT ON THEIR
SURPLUS PROPERTY AND HE SAID OH
THAT'S GOING TO BE A BILL ARE
IN IN THE LEGISLATURE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE- THAT'S
A GOOD QUESTION FOR SURE COURTS
OPEN SO CAN YOU TELL ME IS
THERE SUCH A BILL I WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU. A I'LL JUST ADD THAT THERE
WAS A BILL THAT WAS RELATED TO
THAT I DON'T KNOW THAT IT MOVE
FORWARD THIS YEAR BUT- THERE'S
ALWAYS OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
NEXT SESSION. NEXT IN QUEUE WE
HAVE LINE THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEVE MCNALLY. AND I AM A
RESIDENT OF THE COSTA MESA- I
WANT TO THANK- CHAIRPERSON
QUIRKS SILVA BURKE- PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER. AND I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS WITH
THE L. A. C. IN HER PERSONAL
JOURNEY TO FIND SOLUTIONS. I'M
MCCARTY PETRIE NORRIS SINCE ALL
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. AFTER
SERVING A COUNTY BOARD- BUT ALL
MY COMMENTS TO BE MY PERSONAL
COMMENT COMMENTS BASED ON OUR
LIVING THE PERSONAL JOURNEY OF-
SPECTROMETERS MENTAL ILLNESS.
TO GET A LOT OF SERVICES AND IS
DOING WELL TODAY AND ALL HIS
FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS HAVE BEEN
RESTORED. UNFORTUNATELY I CAME
TO THE PARTY LATE SO I CAME
RIGHT BEFORE- THE U. M. B- LADY
SPOKE. AND RIGHT BEFORE I
THINK- SIX- ASSEMBLY BLOEMEN
ARTWORK SILVA SAID WE NEED TO
LOOK FOR FAIR SHARE. FUNDING
PROPOSAL SO. MY FOCUS IS MENTAL
HEALTH BUT HOMELESSNESS SUICIDE.
AND DRUG ADDICTION ARE ALL PART
OF THE JOURNEY SO MY **** WOULD
BE THAT Y. AND R. WHEN YOURS
WHEN YOUR GROUP GETS TOGETHER-
THAT YOU SPEAK TO SYSTEM USERS.
AND PEOPLE WHO USE THE SYSTEM.
NOT JUST PROVIDERS BOB AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE FOR SERVICE TO.
TWO YEAH FOR DETAILS. THREE
THAT YOU HELP ORANGE COUNTY
MANY TIMES I FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN
A BUBBLE COMPARED TO WHAT ELSE
HAPPENS AROUND THE STATE AND
AROUND THE COUNTRY AS FAR AS
SOLUTION- THAT YOU HELP US GET
OUR 4% BASED ON HOMELESSNESS.
OR 8% BASED ON POPULATION OF
THE HOUSING MONEY COMING DOWN
CLOSE TO TWENTY BILLION AND
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION. IN-
ABORTING CARES. YEAH HE HOPED
AT SEVEN AFTER SENATE THE
EDUCATION MONEY AND HELP THE
GET 8% OF THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES MONEY BECAUSE AT THE
COUNTY WE WALKED ABOUT A
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROPOSITION BECAUSE WE ARE LIKE
7% 8% OF THE POPULATION 4% OF
THE HOMELESS AND JUST RECENTLY
HAVE H. D. D. UPDATED THE-
ACCOUNTS THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WILL RECITE A
SIGNIFICANT JUMP. A KEPT THAT
OUT OF A LOT ABOUT A. NON
COMPETITIVE FUNDING. AS FAR AS-
THIS COUNTY IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
FOUR- THE COUNTY REALLY NEED AS
A AS A CULTURE IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. TO PROTECT THE PAID
SICK- A LOT OF YOUR AMONTILLADO
E. LISTS FROM OF ALL EVERY
PARTICIPANT THAT YOU HAVE. AND
NONE OF THEM HAD EMAIL THAT YOU
ARE HAVING THIS OF THAT. AND I
ONLY FOUND OUT AND I'M VERY
CONNECTED TO A LOT OF THAT
PRODUCT TRINITY. I ONLY FOUND
OUT BY HAPPENSTANCE IN TALKING
TO SOMEBODY AND AUTHENTIC
CONVERSATION LAST NIGHT. SO.
PLEASE COME DOOR KEEP OUR
COUNTY. KAMBAR STEP WITH
SUPERVISOR FALL LEAVES ON- THE
BEAVER HELP ADVISORY BOARD
CONCEPT WITH OTHER- COUNTY
SUPERVISORS AND HOST TOWN HALL.
IT'S NOT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
MONEY IT'S NOT THAT WE DON'T
KNOW THE SOLUTION. WE DON'T
HAVE THE POLITICAL WILL
LEADERSHIP THAT IT TAKES. TO
GET THE JOB DONE. AND THAT'S SO
FRUSTRATING WHEN IT'S MAN MADE
PROBLEMS. AND I'D LIKE TO
IDENTIFY IF IT HAD BEEN MAYBE
IT WAS ALREADY IDENTIFIED BUT I
HAVEN'T HEARD PEOPLE SPEAK TO A
LOT OF SPECIFICS- SO WE ARE
SEVENTY TWO HOT SEVENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED HOMELESS AND THE LAST
COUNT. ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
WORKSHOPS WERE SHELTERED OR
UNSHELTERED MENTAL HEALTH.
THAT'S NOT THE COMPLETE MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEM IF I HAD
SUPPORTING NAVIGATORS BETTER
FUNDED OUT OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE ACT THAT BE A CASELOAD
OF FORTY THREE SIXTEEN HUNDRED.
I THINK I CAN TRACK THEM. IF I
ACTUALLY HAD EVERYBODY IN THE
C. S. SYSTEM. EVENTUALLY
EVERYBODY HAD A PLAN- SO IT'S
JUST FRUSTRATING WHEN. IF WE
CAN'T GET NAVIGATION MAPS WE
CAN'T GET THINGS THAT ARE VERY
SIMPLE AND TAKE VERY LITTLE
TIME TO DO- AND THEN SPEND TONS
OF MONEY TRADING STOCKS- I
DON'T WANT TO SOUND NEGATIVE
I'M NOT NEGATIVE AT ALL. BUT
I'M VERY WELL INFORMED. AND I
WISH CENTER WINNER TO GET BACK
THAT BILL THAT WAS GOING TO
OPEN UP THE PROPERTY ON THE
EDUCATION. AND BAY COMMUNITY.
TO OPEN UP SOME MORE SPACE
BURKE COMMUNITIES THAT MIGHT BE
MORE OPEN TO BEING MPS. AND
LASTLY COOLEY THAT THE COUNTY
FOR THE EIGHTY OR NINETY ACRES
NEXT ABOUT TWENTY TO TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE ACRES THAT GAVE THE
MIND OF SECRETLY IRVINE
FACILITY. THAT'S GOING TO PUT
THEM HOUSING THERE DROPPED OUT
THE SODAS LIKE HELL MOCKINGBIRD
BACK VENTURA. OR LIKE SYNERGY
UP IN SAN FRANCISCO. OR JUST
HOMELESS WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY
GONNA BE HOMELESS PIZZA
PROPERTY THEY'RE- AND BEAR
SHARE THEIR VIEW. WHICH THE
RICH UP THE CURRENT COSTA MESA
PROPOSAL THE GOVERNANCE OF THE
GOOD ONES COMPARED TO WHERE
THEY WERE. BUT THEY USE THE
BILL IT IS A CAPRI ISLAND LAWN
BEACH AS THEIR MODEL. AND YET.
REAL HAS FIFTY AS A FIFTEEN
HUNDRED UNITS. WIDE OPEN SPACES
SERVICES ALL AROUND IT. ON
TWENTY FIVE ACRES AND THEY'RE
LOOKING MORE TO THREE HUNDRED
UNIT BETTER AND VILLAGE IN
COSTA MESA SO. I'M JUST A
REALIST. AND I JUST FELT LIKE
BOTTOM. A SMALL SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE CONTROLLING EVERYTHING.
AND IF THEY WERE NOT AND
BLOCKING THE COMMUNITY AND NOT
LETTING THE COMMUNITY AND BE
INVOLVED AT ALL IT'S VERY SAD
AND FRUSTRATING. AND POSSIBLY
SOME OF YOUR LICENSE
PROFESSIONALS CAN SHARE WITHOUT
THE PSYCHOLOGY OF BUILDING A
SAFE CULTURES WORK LOCATED B.
OKAY TO SPEAK UP IT'S OKAY TO
BE WRONG IT'S OKAY TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION ALONG- AS YOU CAN
TELL OF MY VOICE TROUBLES I
DON'T REALLY LIKE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION. SO MANY OF OUR
PROBLEMS. ARE JUST I'M GOING
THEY JUST NEVER GOT TO DROP.
THANK YOU- WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO THANK
YOU. JUST A REMINDER IT IS
PRESSING ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT NEXT IN
QUEUE WE HAVE LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY WOMAN MY NAME IS BACK
HEY HELLO AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF UNITED TO
END HOMELESSNESS IN ORANGE
COUNTY UNITED WAY. CORRECT I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THIS HEARING AND FOR
BRINGING THIS INFORMATION
FORWARD TO THE COMMUNITY
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON A COUPLE OF
REMARKS MADE BY RICHARD
SANCHEZ- AND HIS INFORMATIVE
PRESENTATION AND JUST ECHOED
THE NEED FOR OUR COMMUNITY TO
BE PREPARED. FOR THE RIDE AND
FOR YOUR HOMELESSNESS BUT WE
ARE SEEING. THE DENNIS CALLAHAN
IS THE LEAD RESEARCHERON THIS.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND HE AND
HIS TEAM ARE PREDICTING VERY
RAPID GROWTH IN KENYA
HOMELESSNESS OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. IT REALLY IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE START TO THINK ABOUT
THAT VERY SERIOUSLY BACK HOME.
BUT WE CAN BE PREPARED AND GET
OUR SYSTEM TO READY FOR THE
INFLUX THAT HAS. ALREADY
UNFORTUNATELY BEGUN. OKAY CAL A
HOME AND THE MOVEMENT OF WHOLE
PERSON CARE TO K. AIM. I JUST
WANTED TO PUT FORWARD HOW AND
IT WILL BE THERE TO BE APPROACH
FUNDING. FOR K. MATTER SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED- UNDER A
CABINET CAL AIM PROGRAM THAT IS
A CRUCIAL PART OF THE SUCCESS
OF THIS- AND SO I HOPE THAT
THAT WILL BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. AND THEN LASTLY
JUST A COUPLE OF COMMENTS FROM
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND HELPING AS HEALTH CARE-
FROM THE COMP STUDY THAT WE DID
WITH YOU SEE I. KNOW THAT
THERE'S A 78% REDUCTION IN
AMBULANCE RIDE. WHEN PEOPLE ARE
PLACED IN THE HOUSING. AS
OPPOSED TO BEING ON THE STREET.
43% REDUCTION AND BUSINESS TO
THE- AGAIN WHEN PEOPLE PLACED
IN DEPARTMENT. HOUSING HOUSING
IS A CRUCIAL PIECE OF HEALTH
CARE FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND PEOPLE WITH
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS ARE PLACED
INTO COME TO COURT HOUSING. IT
SAVED ALL OF US MONEY IN THE
LONG RUN. THANK YOU FOR THE
ABILITY TO SPEAK AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU ARE DOING WITH UNITED
TO OWN- TO END HOMELESSNESS IN
ORANGE COUNTY I KNOW THAT- YOU
ARE DOING- QUITE A BIT BIT OF
WORK AND WE APPRECIATE IT- WILL
TAKE ONE MORE CALL BEFORE WE
END UP. MAKING FINAL COMMENTS.
NEXT WE HAVE ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHURCH SILVA
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS.
HEARING TOGETHER TO HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPORTANCE OF TRANSPORT OF
HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MY NAME IS PHYSICAL RUBIO SOME
WITH THE- CANADA COMMISSION WHO
WORKS TO INCREASE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. WELL ALSO WANTED TO
JUST HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE THINGS
THAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO SEE
THE COLLABORATION THE WORK
THAT'S HAPPENED IN ORANGE
COUNTY CHIU INCREASE OPTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS WORKFRONT WILL
TURN IS TO HOMELESSNESS. BY
INCREASING PORTABLE HOUSING. I
THINK IT'S A GREAT START BUT
IT'S ALSO A GREAT INDICATOR
THAT WE NEED A BROADER
SPECTRUM. OF HOUSING. THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED HERE
LOCAL. TO MAKE SURE THE
HOMELESS AND OUR WORK FOR. IS
THE PLACE HELPING BE OF AND
HOME WHICH IS NOT EXACERBATED.
A LOT OF OVER TIME HERE. ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
AND ARE ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM.
AND WE BIG OF A START OF MORE
HELP AT ALL INCOME. INCLUDING
FROM SUPPORT OF HOW.
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING BUT WE
NEED TO GET THOSE FOLKS THE NON
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THE
HIGH COST COUNTY WHERE THE
MEDIAN INCOME IS A HUNDRED AND
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND
RENTS ARE OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE OF THE SPECTRUM OF
HOUSING. AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
AND FOR THAT I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T FORGET
THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE
HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES TO ENSURE
THAT. WE HAVE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WE DON'T HAVE MUCH
FURTHER. TALKS FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND CONTINUE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
YOUR STAFF AND BUT THE
LEGISLATOR IN THE DIRECTION
ISSUES. HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY
ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I. THE TIME
THAT YOU BEEN DO A WITH THE CAN
CAN COMING. OVER A DECADE NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BUT WITH THAT
WE WILL BE CLOSING OUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND I WILL JUST FINISH
UP BY AGAIN THANKING ALL OF.
THE PANELISTS THINKING- THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT CALLED IN AND
THINKING THOSE THAT ARE
LISTENING TO THIS BROADCAST-
THIS IS A FORMAL SELECT HEARING
BEING BROADCAST THROUGH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
CAPITAL HERE- JUST TELL US A TO
MAKE A NOTE. THIS IS DIFFERENT
THAN A TOWN HALL OR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BECAUSE THIS IS A
FORMAL RECORD THAT- WE WILL BE
ABLE TO ADD. TO WHAT WE ARE
DOING HERE ON HOMELESSNESS AS A
SELECT COMMITTEE I DO OFFER
MANY TIMES MORE INFORMAL
OPPORTUNITIES WITH COMMUNITY
CONVERSATIONS WITH ROUND TABLES
IN THE DISTRICT AND WE HOPE-
WHEN SAFE WE CAN GET BACK OUT.
BUT TO DO THE SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE DISTRICT AS WE
WERE ABLE TO IN THE PAST. FEW
FINAL THOUGHTS. I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THIS TYPE OF
EXPERIENCE AS I LEARN WHETHER
IT'S NEW FACTS NEW INFORMATION
I ALWAYS- TAKE SOMETHING AWAY I
CERTAINLY TAKE THE ENTHUSIASM
FROM OUR OUR OF. A LEADER AT
THE SALVATION ARMY I TAKE THE
HARD NUMBERS OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN
AT THE- LOCAL LEVEL WHEN WE SAY
NO TO PROJECT. SWITCH OF COMING
FROM A MISS HANS BERG I ALSO
TAKE- THE GREAT IN TWO THOUSAND
BETWEEN SOME OF OUR PARTNERS
WORKING IN THE INTEGRATED-
SPEAR THERE WITH DIFFERENT
MODELS FOR CARE. BUT LET ME BE
CLEAR WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS LIKE THIS A YEAR
FROM NOW TWO YEARS FROM NOW TEN
YEARS FROM NOW IF WE DO
NOTHING. ORANGE COUNTY HAS PUT
THEMSELVES IN A POSITION WHERE
THEY'RE TAKING THIS ISSUE
SERIOUSLY BUT WE CANNOT REST ON
OUR LAURELS AS THEY SAY BECAUSE
WE HAVE MUCH WORK TO DO- WE
HAVE GREAT PARTNERS OUT THERE
WE HAVE PASSIONATE PEOPLE. BUT
IT COMES DOWN TO US BUILDING
YES BUILDING I KNOW SOMEOF YOU
DON'T LIKE THAT WORD UP AND
ALSO- PROVIDING MODELS THAT WE
KNOW WORK AND THERE ARE MODELS
THAT WORK. IN FACT ORANGE
COUNTY IS LEADING AND SOME OF
THOSE AREAS BUT WE MUST SAY YES
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TWO AS WAS
JUST NOTED. WORK FORCE HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKET RATE
HOUSING AND THIS IS PART OF
WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU ARE A BOLD
LEADER YOU SAY YES INSTEAD OF
NO SO WITH THAT I WISH YOU ALL
THE BEST AND HAVE A GREAT
WEEKEND THANK YOU SO MUCH.